the following is a conversation with
doug lennon
creator of psych a system that for close
to 40 years and still today has sought
to solve the core problem of artificial
intelligence the acquisition of common
sense knowledge and the use of that
knowledge to think to reason and to
understand the world
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
as a side note let me say that in the
excitement of the modern era of machine
learning it is easy to forget just how
little we understand exactly how to
build the kind of intelligence that
matches the power of the human mind
to me many of the core ideas behind
psych in some form in actuality or in
spirit will likely be part of the ai
system that achieves general super
intelligence but perhaps more
importantly solving this problem of
common sense knowledge will help us
humans understand our own minds the
nature of truth and finally how to be
more rational and more kind to each
other
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation with doug
leonard
psyc is a project launched by you in
1984
and still is active today
whose goal is to assemble a knowledge
base that spans the basic concepts and
rules about how the world works
in other words it hopes to capture
common sense knowledge
which is a lot harder than it sounds
can you elaborate on this mission and
maybe perhaps speak to the various
sub-goals within this mission
when
i was a
faculty member in the computer science
department at stanford
my colleagues and i
did research in
all sorts of artificial intelligence
programs so natural language
understanding programs robots expert
systems
and so on
and we kept hitting the very same brick
wall
our systems would have
impressive early successes
and so if your only goal was academic
namely to
get enough material to write a journal
article
that might actually suffice but if
you're really trying to get ai
then you have to somehow get past the
brick wall and the brick wall was
the programs didn't have
what we would call common sense they
didn't have general world knowledge they
didn't really understand what they were
doing what they were saying what they
were being asked
and so very much like a
clever dog performing tricks we could
get them to do tricks but they never
really understood what they were doing
sort of like when
you get a dog to fetch your morning
newspaper
the dog might do that successfully but
the dog has no idea what a newspaper is
or what it says or anything like that
what does it mean to understand
something can you maybe elaborate on
that a little bit is it is understand an
action
of like combining little things together
like through inference or is
understanding the wisdom you gain over
time that forms the knowledge i think of
understanding more like a um
think of it more like the ground you
stand on
which
could be very shaky could be very unsafe
but most of the time is not because
underneath it is more ground
and eventually you know rock and and
other things but
layer after layer after layer that solid
foundation is there and you rarely need
to think about it you rarely need to
count on it but occasionally you do
and
i've never used this analogy before so
bear with me but i think the same thing
is true in in terms of getting computers
to understand things which is
uh you ask
a computer a question for instance alexa
or
some robot or something and
um maybe it gets the right answer
but if you were asking that of a human
you could also say things like why
or how might you be wrong about this or
something like that and the person you
know would would answer you and you know
it might be a little annoying if you
have a small child and they keep asking
why questions in series eventually you
get to the point where you throw up your
hands and say i don't know it's just the
way the world is but for many layers you
actually have that that layered solid
foundation of support so that when you
need it
you can count on it and when do you need
it well when things are unexpected when
you come up against a situation which is
novel for instance when you're driving
it may be
fine to have a small program a small set
of rules that cover you know 99 of the
cases but that one percent of the time
when something strange happens
you really need to draw on common sense
for instance um my wife and i were
driving recently
and there was a trash truck in front of
us
and i guess they had packed it too full
and the back exploded and trash bags
went everywhere
and we had to you know make a split
second decision are we going to slam on
our brakes are we going to swerve into
another lane are we going to just run it
over
because there are cars all around us
and you know in front of us was a large
trash bag and we know what we throw away
in trash bags probably not a safe thing
to run over um over on the the left was
um a bunch of fast food restaurant um
trash bags and it's like oh well those
things are just like styrofoam and
leftover food we'll run over that and so
that was a safe thing for us to to do
now that's the kind of thing that's
going to happen maybe once in your life
and um
but the point is that there's almost no
telling
what little bits of knowledge about the
world you might actually need
in some situations which were unforeseen
but see when you sit on that mountain
or that ground that goes deep of
knowledge
in order to make a split-second decision
about fast food trash or random trash
from the back of a
trash truck
you need to be able to leverage that
ground you stand on in some way it's not
merely
you know it's not enough to just have a
lot of ground to stand on it's your
ability to leverage it to utilize in a
split like integrate it all together to
make that split second decision
and i i suppose
understanding isn't just
having uh
common sense knowledge to access
it's the act of accessing accessing it
somehow like correctly
filtering out the parts of the knowledge
are not useful selecting only the useful
parts and uh
effectively making conclusive decisions
so let's tease apart
two different tasks really both of which
are incredibly important and even
necessary
if you're going to have this in a usable
useful usable fashion as opposed to say
like library books sitting on a shelf
and so on
where the knowledge might be there but
you know if a fire comes the books are
going to burn because they don't know
what's in them and they're just going to
sit there while they burn um so there
are two there are two
aspects of using the knowledge one is a
kind of a theoretical
how is it possible at all
and then the second aspect of what you
said is how can you do it quickly enough
right um so how can you do it at all is
something that philosophers have
grappled with and fortunately
philosophers 100 years ago and even
earlier
developed a kind of
formal language
like english
it's called
predicate logic or first order logic or
something like predicate calculus and so
on so there's a way of representing
things
in this formal language
which
enables a mechanical procedure to sort
of grind through
and algorithmically produce all of the
same logical
entailments all the same logical
conclusions that you or i would from
that same set of pieces of information
that are represented that way
um so um that that sort of raises um a
couple questions one is how do you get
all this information from say
observations and english and so on into
this logical form right and secondly how
can you then efficiently um run these
algorithms to actually get the
information you need in in the case i
mentioned in a tenth of a second rather
than say i'm in you know 10 hours or 10
000 years of computation
um and those are both really important
um
uh questions and like a corollary
addition to the first one is how many
such
things do you need to gather for it to
be useful in certain contexts
so like what
in order you mention philosophers in
order to capture this world and
represent it
in a logical way and with a formal logic
like
how many statements are required is it
five is it ten is it ten trillion is it
like that that's
as far as i understand is uh probably
still an open question it may forever be
an open question uh
just to say like definitively about
to describe the universe perfectly well
how many facts do you need
i i guess i'm going to disappoint you by
giving you an actual answer to your
question okay um well no this sounds
exciting
yes okay so so now we have like um three
three things to talk about we'll keep
adding more that's okay the first and
the third are related yes um so let's
leave the efficiency question aside for
now so um how how does all this
information get represented in
logical form so that these algorithms
resolution theorem proving and other
algorithms can actually grind through
all the logical consequences of what you
said
and that ties into your question about
well how many of these things do you
need
because if the answer is small enough
then by hand you could write them out
one at a time
so
in
the
19 early 1984
i held a meeting at stanford where i was
a
faculty member there
where we assembled
about half a dozen of the smartest
people i know
people like
alan newell and marvin minsky and alan
kaye
and
um um a few others was firemen there by
chance because he he liked your he
commented about your system urisco at
the time no no he he wasn't part of this
meeting um but that's a heck of a
meeting anyway i think ed feigenbaum was
there i think um josh lederberg was
there so we we have um
all these different um smart people and
we were um
we came together
to
address the question
that that you raised which is if it's
important to represent common sense
knowledge and world knowledge in order
for ais to not be brittle
in order for ais not to just have the
veneer of intelligence well how many
pieces
of common sense how many if then rules
for instance would we have to actually
write in order to essentially cover what
what people expect
perfect strangers to already know about
the world
and
i expected there would be an enormous
divergence of opinion um and computation
but amazingly everyone got an answer
which was around a million
and one person one person got the answer
by saying well
look you can only burn into human
long-term memory a certain number of
things per unit time like maybe one
every 30 seconds or something and other
than that it's just short-term memory
and it flows away like water and so on
so by the time you're say 10 years old
or so um how many things could you
possibly have burned into your long-term
memory and it's like about a million
another person went a completely
different direction and said well if you
look at the number of words
in a
dictionary not a whole dictionary but
for someone to
essentially be considered to be fluent
in a language how many words would they
need to know and then about how many
things about each word would you have to
tell it and so they got to a million
that way
another another person said well let's
actually look at one single
short one volume desk encyclopedia
article
and so we'll look at you know what was
like a um a four paragraph article or
something i think about grebes grebes
are a type of waterfowl
and if we were going to sit there and
represent every single thing that was
there um how many assertions or rules or
statements would we have to write in
this logical language and so on and then
multiply that by all of the number of
articles that there were and so on
so all of these estimates came out with
a million
and so
if you do the math it turns out that
like oh well then maybe in
something like
a hundred
years
in one or two person centuries we could
actually get
this written down by hand and
a marvelous
coincidence an opportunity existed right
at that point in time the early 1980s
there was something called the japanese
fifth generation computing effort japan
had threatened to do in computing and ai
and hardware what they had just finished
doing in consumer electronics on the
automotive industry namely resting
control away
from the united states and more
generally away from the west
and so america was scared
and
congress did something that's how you
know it was a long time ago because
congress did something
congress passed something called the
national cooperative research act ncra
and what it said was hey all you big
american companies that's also how you
know it was a long time ago because they
were american companies rather than
multinational companies hey all you big
american companies
normally it would be an anti-trust
violation if you colluded on r d but we
promise for the next 10 years we won't
prosecute any of you if you do that
to help combat this threat and so
overnight
the first two consortia research
consortia in america sprang up
both of them coincidentally in austin
texas uh one called sematech focusing on
hardware chips and so on and then one
called mcc the microelectronics and
computer technology corporation focusing
on more on software on databases and ai
and natural language understanding and
things like that
and
i got the opportunity thanks to my
friend woody bledsoe
who was one of the people who founded
that to come and be its principal
scientist and he said you know
and he said admiral bob inman who was
the person running mcc uh came and
talked to me and said look professor you
know you're talking about doing this
project it's going to involve
person centuries of effort
if you've only got a handful of graduate
students you do the math it's going to
take you like
you know
longer than the rest of your life to
finish this project but if you move to
the wilds of austin texas
we'll put 10 times as many people on it
and
you know you'll be done in
a few years and so that was pretty
exciting and so um i did that i
took my leave from stanford i came to to
austin i worked for mcc and
good news and bad news the bad news is
that all of us were off by an order of
magnitude
that it turns out what you need are tens
of millions of these
pieces of knowledge about on every day
sort of like if you have a coffee cup
with stuff in it and you turn it upside
down the stuff in it's going to fall out
so you need tens of millions of pieces
of knowledge like that even if you take
trouble to make each one as general as
it possibly could be
but
the good news was that thanks to
initially the fifth generation effort
and then later
u.s government
agency funding and so on we were able to
get enough funding not for a couple
person centuries of time but for a
couple person millennia of time which is
what we've spent since 1984
getting psych to contain the tens of
millions of rules that it needs in order
to really capture uh and span uh sort of
not all of human knowledge but the
things that you assume other people the
things you count on other people knowing
and
so by now we've done that
and the good news is since you've waited
38 years just about to talk to me
we're about at the
at the end of that process so most of
what we're doing now is not putting in
even what you would consider common
sense but more putting in
domain-specific application-specific
knowledge about
healthcare
in a certain hospital or about um
oil um pipes getting um clogged up or
whatever the applications happen to be
so we've almost come full circle and
we're doing things very much like the
expert systems of the 1970s and the
1980s except instead of resting on
nothing and being brittle they're now
resting on this massive pyramid if you
will this massive lattice of common
sense knowledge so that when things go
wrong when something unexpected happens
they can fall back on more and more and
more general principles
eventually bottoming out in things like
for instance if we have a problem with
the microphone one of the things you'll
do is
unplug it plug it in again and hope for
the best right because that's one of the
general pieces of knowledge you have in
dealing with electronic equipment or
software systems or
things like that is there a basic
principle like that like is it possible
to encode something that generally
captures this idea of
turn it off and turn it back on and see
if it fixes oh absolutely that's one of
the things that
that's like news that's actually one of
the fundamental
laws of nature i believe
i wouldn't i wouldn't call it a law it's
it's more like a um
it seems to work every time so it sure
sure is like looks like a law i don't
know so that um that basically um
covered the um the resources needed and
then we had to devise a method to
actually figure out well what are the
tens of millions of things that we need
to tell the system and for that we found
a few
techniques which worked really well one
is to take um any piece of text almost
it could be an advertisement it could be
a transcript it could be a novel it
could be an article
and don't pay attention to the actual
type that's there the the black space on
the white page pay attention to the
complement of that the white space if
you will so what did the writer of this
sentence
assume that the reader already knew
about the world for instance if they
used a pronoun
how did they figure out that why did
they think that you would be able to
understand what the intended referent of
that pronoun was if they used an
ambiguous word how did they think that
you would be able to figure out what
they meant by that word
the other thing we look at is the gap
between one sentence and the next one
what are all the things that the writer
expected you to fill in and infer
occurred between the end of one sentence
and the beginning of the other so like
if the sentence says
fred smith robbed the third national
bank period
he was sentenced to 20 years in prison
period well between the first sentence
and the second you're expected to infer
things like fred got caught fred
got arrested fred went to jail fred had
a trial fred was found guilty
and so on if my next sentence starts out
with something like the judge dot dot
dot um then you assume it's the judge at
his trial if my next sentence starts out
something like the arresting officer dot
dot dot you assumed that it was the
police officer who arrested him after he
committed the crime and so on so um
that's it those are two techniques for
getting um
that knowledge the the other thing we
sometimes look at is uh sort of like
fake news or uh sort of humorous um
onion headlines or um headlines in um
the weekly world news if you know what
that is or the national enquirer where
it's like oh we don't believe this then
we introspect on why don't we believe it
so they're things like um
b17 lands on the moon you know it's like
why don't we what do we know about the
world that causes us to believe that
that's just silly or uh something like
that or um another thing we look for are
contradictions um where with things
which can't both be true um and we say
to like what is it that we know that
causes us to know that both of these
can't be true at the same at the same
time for instance in one of the weekly
world news um
editions in one article it talked about
how elvis was cited um you know even
though he was uh you know getting on in
years and so on and another article in
the same one talked about people seeing
elvis ghost
okay so it's like why why do we believe
that at least one of these articles you
know must be wrong
and so on so um so we have a series of
techniques like that that enable our
people um and by now uh we have about 50
people working full-time on this and
have for for decades so we've put in the
thousands of person years of effort
we've built up these tens of millions of
rules we constantly
police the system to make sure that
we're saying things as generally as we
possibly can
so
you don't want to say things like um no
mouse is also a moose
because if you said things like that
then you'd have to add another one or
two or three zeros onto the number of
assertions you'd actually have to have
so
at some point we generalize things more
and more and we get to a point where we
say oh yeah for any two biological
taxons if we don't know explicitly that
one is a generalization of another then
almost certainly they're disjoint
a member of one is not going to be a
member of the other and so on so and the
same thing with the elvis and the ghost
it has nothing to do with elvis it's
more about
the human nature and then the the
mortality and well right in general
things are not both alive and dead at
the same time yeah and unless special
cats in in theoretical physics examples
well that raises um a couple important
points well that's the onion headline
situation type of thing okay sorry but
no no so so what you bring up is this
really important point of like well how
do you handle exceptions and
inconsistencies
and so on um and one of the hardest
lessons for us to learn it took us about
five years to to really grit our teeth
and
learned to love it
is we had to give up global consistency
so the knowledge base can no longer be
consistent so this is a kind of scary
thought i grew up watching star trek and
anytime a computer was inconsistent it
would either freeze up or explode or
take over the world or something bad
would happen
or if you come from a mathematics
background once you can prove false you
can prove anything so that's not good
and so on so
that's why on the
old knowledge-based systems were all
very very consistent but the trouble is
that
by and large our models of the world the
way we talk about the world and so on
there are all sorts of inconsistencies
that creep in here and there
that will sort of kill some attempt to
build some enormous globally consistent
knowledge base and so what we had to
move to
was a system of local consistency so a
good analogy is you know that the
surface of the earth is more or less
spherical
globally
but you live your life every day as
though the surface of the earth were
flat you know when you're talking to
someone in australia you don't think of
them as being oriented upside down to
you when you're planning a trip you know
even if it's a thousand miles away
you may think a little bit about time
zones but you rarely think about the
curvature of the earth and so on and for
most purposes you can live your whole
life without really worrying about that
because the earth is locally flat
in much the same way the psych knowledge
base is divided up into almost like
tectonic plates which are individual
contexts and each context
is more or less consistent but there can
be
small inconsistencies at the boundary
between one context and the next one and
so on and so by the time you move say 20
contexts over there could be glaring
inconsistencies so eventually you get
from the normal modern real world
context that we're in right now to
something you know like um road runner
cartoon context where physics is very
different and in fact life and death are
very different because no matter how
many times he's killed you know the
coyote comes back in the next scene and
and so on
so um that that was a hard lesson to
learn and we had to make sure that our
representation language the way we the
way that we actually encode the
knowledge and represent it was
expressive enough that we could talk
about things being true in one context
and false in another things that are
true at one time and false in another
things that are true let's say in one
region like one country but false in
another things that are true in one
person's belief system
but false in another person's belief
system things that are true at one level
of abstraction and false at another for
instance at one level of abstraction
you think of this table as a solid
object but at you know down at the
atomic level it's mostly empty space and
so on so then that's fascinating and but
it puts a lot of pressure on context to
do a lot of work so you say tectonic
plates is it possible to formulate
contacts that are general and big
that do this kind of capture of
knowledge bases
or do you then get turtles on top of
turtles again where there's just a huge
number of contexts so it's good you ask
that question because
you're pointed in the right direction
which is
you want context to be
first class objects
in your system's knowledge base in
particular in sykes knowledge base
and by first class object i mean that
it should we should be able to have
psych think about and talk about and
reason about
one context or another context the same
way it reasons about coffee cups and
tables and people and fishing and so on
and so contexts are just terms in its
language just like the ones i mentioned
and so psych can reason about
context context can arrange
hierarchically and so on
and so you can say things about let's
say
things that are true in the modern era
things that are true in a particular
year would then be a sub context of the
the things that are true in um abroad
let's say a century or a millennium or
something like that things that are true
in austin texas are generally going to
be a specialization of
things that are true in texas which is
going to be a specialization of things
that are true in the united states and
so on
and so you don't have to say things over
and over over again at all these levels
you just say things at the most general
level that it applies to and you only
have to say it once and then it
essentially inherits to all these more
specific
contexts ask a slightly technical
question is this inherent in an
inheritance a tree or a graph oh you
definitely have to think of it as a
graph
so we could talk about for instance why
the japanese fifth generation computing
effort failed there were about half a
dozen different reasons one of the
reasons they failed was because they
tried to represent knowledge as a tree
rather than as a graph
and so each node in their
representation
could only have one parent
node so if you had a table that was a
wooden object a black object a flat
object and so you have to choose one and
that's the only parent it could have
when of course you know depending on
what it is you need to reason about it
sometimes it's important to know that
it's made out of wood like if we're
talking about a fire sometimes it's
important to know that it's flat if
we're talking about resting something on
it and so on so
um one of the one of the problems was
that they wanted a kind of dewey decimal
numbering system for all of their
concepts which meant that each node
could only have at most
10 children and each node could only
have one parent
and
while that does enable the dewey decimal
type
numbering of concepts labeling of
concepts
it prevents you from representing all
the things you need to about objects in
our in our world and that was one of the
things which um they never were able to
overcome and i think that was one of the
main reasons that that project failed so
we'll return to some of the doors you've
opened but if we can go back to that
room in 1984 around there with marvin
minsky yeah
but by the way i should mention that
marvin um wouldn't do his estimate until
someone brought him an envelope so that
he could literally do a back of the
envelope calculations to come up with
his number
well because i i feel like
the conversation in that room is an
important one
you know this this how um
sometimes science is done in this way a
few people get together and plant the
seed of ideas and they reverberate
throughout history and some some kind of
dissipating disappear and some
you know drake equation and you know
they you know seems like a meaningless
equation somewhat meaningless but i
think it drives and motivates a lot of
scientists and when the aliens finally
show up
that equation will get even more uh
valuable because then we'll get be able
to in the long arc of history the drake
equation will
um
will prove to be
quite useful
i think in that same way a conversation
of just how many facts
are required to capture the basic common
sense knowledge of the world that's a
fascinating question i want to
distinguish between what you think of as
facts and the kind of things that we
represent so
um we we map to and essentially make
sure that psych has the ability to as it
were read and access the kind of facts
you might find say
in wikidata or stated in a wikipedia
article or something like that so what
we're representing the things that we
need a small number of tens of millions
of are more like rules of thumb rules of
good guessing things which are usually
true and which help you to make sense of
the
facts that are on sort of sitting off in
some database or some other more static
story so they're almost like platonic
forms so like when you read stuff on
wikipedia that's going to be like
projections of those ideas you read an
article about the fact that elvis died
that's a projection of the idea that uh
humans are mortal and like you know very
few wikipedia articles will write humans
are immortal
exactly and that's what i meant about
ferreting out the unstated things in
texas what are all the things that were
assumed and so those are things like um
if you have a problem with something
turning it off and on um often fixes it
for reasons we don't really understand
and we're not happy about or
people can't be both alive and dead at
the same time and or water flows
downhill if you search online for water
flowing uphill and water flowing
downhill you'll find more references for
water flowing uphill because it's used
as a kind of a
metaphorical reference for some unlikely
thing because of course everyone already
knows that water flows downhill so why
would anyone bother saying that do you
have a word you prefer
because we said facts isn't the right
word is there a word like concepts i
would say assertions
assertions or rules because i'm not
talking about rigid rules but rules of
thumb but assertions
is a nice one that covers
all of these things yeah as a programmer
to me a cert
has a very dogmatic authoritarian feel
to them i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry okay but assertions works
okay so if we go back to that room with
marvel minsky with you
all these seminal figures uh
uh ed foggy mom
thinking about
this very
philosophical but also engineering
question
we can also go back a couple of decades
before then and thinking about
artificial intelligence broadly when
people were thinking about you know how
do you create super intelligent systems
general intelligence
and i think people's intuition was
off
at the time
and i mean this continues to be the case
that we're not
when we're grappling with these
exceptionally difficult ideas we're not
always it's very difficult to
truly understand ourselves when we're
thinking about the human mind
to to introspect how difficult it is to
engineer intelligence to solve
intelligence we're not very good at
estimating that
and
you are somebody who has really stayed
with this question for decades
do you what's your sense
from the 1984 to today
have you gotten a stronger
sense of just how much knowledge is
required so you've kind of said
with some level of certainty that's
still on the order of magnitude of tens
of millions right but for the first
several years i would have said that it
was on the order of one or two million
yeah and so um it took it took us about
five or six years to realize that we
were off
um by by a factor of 10. but i guess
what i'm asking you know marvin miska is
very confident in the 60s when you say
yes right
what's your
sense
if you
you know 200 years from now
you're still
you know you're you're not going to be
any longer in this particular biological
body but your brain will still be
uh in the digital form and you'll be
looking back
would you think you were
smart today
like your intuition was right or do you
think
you may be really off
so i i think i'm i'm right enough and
let me explain what i mean by that which
is
um
sometimes like if you have an
old-fashioned pump you have to prime the
pump yeah and then eventually it starts
so
i think i'm i'm right enough in the
sense that
what we what we've built yeah even if it
isn't so to speak everything you need
it's primed the knowledge pump enough
that
psych can now itself
help to
learn more and more automatically on its
own by reading things and understanding
and occasionally asking questions like a
student would or something and by doing
experiments and discovering things on
its own and so on so through a
combination of
psych-powered discovery and
psych-powered reading
it will be able to bootstrap itself
maybe it's the final two percent maybe
it's the final 99
so even if i'm if i'm wrong
all i really need to build is a system
which has primed the pump enough that it
can begin
that cascade upward that
self-reinforcing
sort of quadratically or maybe even
exponentially increasing
path upward um that we get from for
instance talking with each other that's
why um
humans today know so much more than
humans a hundred thousand years ago
we're not really that much smarter than
people were a hundred thousand years ago
but there's so much more knowledge and
we have language and we can communicate
we can check things on google and so on
so effectively we have this enormous
power at our fingertips
and there's almost no limit to how much
you could learn if you wanted to because
you've already gotten to a certain level
of understanding of the world that
enables you to read all these articles
and understand them that enables you to
go out and if necessary do experiments
although that's slower as a way of
gathering data and so on and and i think
this is really an important point which
is
if we have artificial intelligence real
general artificial intelligence human
level artificial intelligence
then
people will become smarter
um it's not so much that it'll be us
versus the ais it's more like us and the
ais together we'll be able to do things
that require more creativity
that would take too long right now but
we'll be able to do lots of things in
parallel we'll be able to misunderstand
each other less
[Music]
there's all sorts of
value that effectively for an individual
would mean that individual will for all
intents and purposes be smarter
and that means that humanity as a
species will be smarter and when was the
last time that any invention
qualitatively
made a huge difference in human
intelligence um you have to go back a
long ways it wasn't like the internet or
the computer or mathematics or something
it was all the way back to the
development of language we sort of look
back on pre-linguistic cavemen as well
you know they they weren't really
intelligent were they they weren't
really human were they and i think that
um as you said 50 100 200 years from now
people will look back on people today
um
right before the advent of these sort of
lifelong general ai muses
and say you know those poor those poor
people they weren't really human were
they
exactly so you said a lot of really
interesting things by the way i would
maybe
uh try to argue that the internet
is on is on the order of
um
the kind of big leap in improvement that
the invention of language was it's
certainly a big leap in one direction
we're not sure whether it's upward or
downward well i i mean very specific
parts of the internet which is access to
information like a website like
wikipedia
like ability for human beings from
across the world to access information
so very quickly so i i could take either
side of this argument and since you just
took one side i'll give you the other
side which is that
almost nothing has done more harm
than something like the internet and
access to that information
in two ways one is it's made people more
globally ignorant
in the same way that calculators
made us
more or less innumerate so when i was
growing up we had to use slide rules we
had to be able to estimate yeah and so
on today
people don't really understand numbers
they don't really understand math they
don't really estimate very well at all
and so on they don't really understand
the difference between trillions and
billions and millions and so on very
well
because calculators do that all for us
um and um thanks to uh things like the
internet and search engines um
that same kind of juvenilism
is reinforced in making people
essentially be able to live their whole
lives not just without being able to do
arithmetic and estimate but now without
actually having to really know almost
anything because anytime they need to
know something they'll just go and look
it up right and i can tell you could
play both sides of this and it is a
double-edged sword you can of course say
the same thing about language probably
people when they invented language they
would criticize you know it used to be
we would just if we're angry we would
just kill a person and if we're in love
we'll just have sex with them and now
everybody's writing poetry and [ __ ]
that you know you should just be direct
you should like have physical contact
enough with this words and books and
it's you're you're not actually
experiencing like if you read a book
you're not experiencing the thing this
is nonsense that's right if you read a
book about how to make butter that's not
the same as if you had to like learn it
and do it yourself exactly
and so on so so let's just say that
something is gained but something is
lost every time you have um these these
sorts of dependencies um on technology
um and overall i think that the um
having smarter individuals and having
smarter ai augmented
human species
will be
one of the few ways that we'll actually
be able to overcome some of the global
problems we have involving
poverty and starvation and global
warming and
overcrowding all the other
problems that that are besetting
the planet we really need to be smarter
and they're really only two routes to
being smarter one is through
biochemistry and
genetics
genetic engineering
the other route is through having
general ais that
augment our intelligence
and
you know hopefully one of those two
ways of
paths to salvation will will come
through before it's too late yeah
absolutely i agree with you and
obviously as an engineer i have
um
i have a better sense and an optimism
about the technology side of things
because you can control things there
more biology is just such a giant mess
we're living through a pandemic now
there's so many ways that nature can
just be just destructive and destructive
in a way where it doesn't even notice
you you're not it's not like a battle
of humans versus virus it's just like
huh okay and then you can just wipe out
an entire species
the other problem with the internet
is that it has enabled
us to surround ourselves with an echo
chamber with a bubble of like-minded
people which means that you can have
truly bizarre
theories conspiracy theories fake news
and so on
promulgate
and surround yourself with people who
essentially reinforce
um what you want to believe or what you
already believe about the world
and in the in the old days that was much
harder to do when you had say only three
tv networks or even before when you had
no tv networks and you had to actually
like look at the world and make your own
reasoned decisions i like the push and
pull of our dance that we're doing
because then i'll just say in the old
world having come from the soviet union
because you had won a couple of networks
then propaganda could be much more
effective and then the government can
overpower its people by telling you the
truth
and then
starving millions and torturing millions
and putting millions into camps and
starting wars with a propaganda machine
allowing you to believe that you're
actually good doing good in the world
with the internet because of all the
quote unquote conspiracy theories
some of them are actually challenging
the power centers the very kind of power
centers that a century ago would have
led to
the death of millions so there's a it's
again this double-edged sword and i i
very much agree with you on the ai side
it's it's often an intuition that people
have that somehow ai will be used to
maybe overpower people by certain select
groups
and to me it's not all obvious that
that's the likely scenario to me the
likely scenario
especially just having observed the
trajectory of technology is it'll be
used to empower people it'll be used to
extend
the capabilities of
individuals
across the world because there's a lot
of money to be made that way
like improving people's lives you can
make a lot of money agree i think that
the
the main the main thing that
ai
prosthesis ai amplifiers will do for
people is make it easier maybe even
unavoidable for them to do good critical
thinking
um so pointing out logical fallacies
logical contradictions and so on in
things that they otherwise would just
blithely believe
pointing out
essentially
data which
they should take into consideration
if they really want to
learn the truth about something and so
on so i think
doing not just educating in the sense of
pouring facts into people's heads but
educating in the sense of arming people
with the ability to do good critical
thinking is enormously powerful
the education system
that we have in the u.s and worldwide
generally don't do a good job of that um
but
i believe that the ai
the ais can and will in the same way
that everyone can have their own um um
alexa or siri or
google assistant or whatever um um
everyone will have this sort of cradle
to grave assistant
which will get to know you which you'll
get to trust it'll model you you'll
model it
and
it'll call to your attention things
which will in some sense make your life
better easier less
mistake written and so on less regret
written
if you listen to listen to it yeah i'm
in full agreement with you about
this like space of technologies and i
think it's super exciting from my
perspective integrating emotional
intelligence so even things like
friendship and companionship and love
into those kinds of systems
as opposed to helping you just grow
intellectually as a human being allow
you to grow emotionally which is
ultimately what makes life
amazing is to to sort of
you know the the old pursuit of
happiness so it's not just the pursuit
of reason it's the pursuit of happiness
yes
the full spectrum well let me um sort of
because you mentioned so many
fascinating things let me jump back to
the
idea of automated reasoning
so
the acquisition of new knowledge
has been done in this very interesting
way
but primarily by humans
doing this um yes you can think of
monks in their cells in medieval europe
um you know carefully illuminating
manuscripts and so on it's a very
difficult and amazing process actually
because it allows you to truly ask the
question about
the
in the white space what is assumed i
think this exercise
is um like very few people do this right
they just
do it subconsciously they perform by
definition but because because those
pieces of elided of omitted information
of those missing steps as it were
are pieces of common sense if you
actually included all of them it would
it would almost be offensive or
confusing to the readers like why are
they telling me all these of course i
know that you know all these things
and so um
so it's one of these things which almost
by its very nature
um has has
almost never been explicitly written
down anywhere
because
by the time you're old enough to talk to
other people and so on um you know if
you survived to that age presumably you
already got pieces of common sense like
um you know if something causes you pain
whenever you do it probably not a good
idea to keep doing it
uh so
what ideas do you have given how
difficult this step is
what ideas are there for how to do it
automatically without
using humans or at least not um
you know doing like a large percentage
of the work for humans and then humans
only do the
very high level supervisory work
so we have um uh in fact
two directions we're pushing on very
very heavily uh currently at sitecore
and one involves natural language
understanding and the ability to read
what people have explicitly written down
and and to to pull knowledge in that way
but the other is
to build a series of
knowledge editing tools knowledge entry
tools knowledge
capture tools knowledge
testing tools and so on think of them as
like user interface
suite of software tools if you want
something that will help people to more
or less automatically
expand and extend the system um
in areas where for instance they want to
build some app have it do some
application or something
like that so i'll give you an example of
one
which is something called
abduction so you've probably heard of
like deduction
and
induction and so on but abduction is
unlike this abduction is not
sound
it's just useful so
uh for instance um
deductively if someone is out in the
rain and they're going to get all wet
and
when they enter room they might be all
wet and so on
so that's deduction
but if someone were to walk into the
room right now
and they were dripping wet
we would immediately look outside to say
oh did it start to rain or something
like that now
why did we say maybe it started to rain
that's not a sound logical inference but
it's certainly a reasonable
abductive
leap to say well one of the most common
ways that a person would have gotten
dripping wet is if they had gotten
caught out in the rain or something like
that um so um
what what does that have to do with what
we were talking about so suppose you're
building one of these applications and
the system gets some answer wrong
and you say oh yeah the answer to this
question is
this one not the one you came up with
then what the system can do is it can
use everything it already knows about
common sense general knowledge the
domain you've already been telling it
about
and context like we talked about and so
on and say well here are
seven alternatives each of which i
believe is plausible given everything i
already know and if any of these seven
things were true i would have come up
with the answer you just gave me instead
of the wrong answer i came up with is
one of these seven things true and then
you the expert will look at those
on seven things and say oh yeah number
five is actually true and so without
actually having to tinker down at the
level of logical assertions and so on um
you'll be able to educate
the system in the same way that you
would help educate another person who
you were trying to apprentice or
something like that so that that
significantly reduces the mental effort
or significantly increases the
efficiency of the teacher the human
teacher exactly and it makes more or
less anyone able to to be a teacher um
in that um in that way so that's that's
part of the the answer and then the
other is that
the system on its own will be able to um
through reading through
conversations with other people and so
on um learn the same way that um you or
i or other humans do
first of all that's that's a beautiful
vision um i'll have to ask you about
semantic webinar in a second here but
first uh
are there
when we talk about specific techniques
do you find something inspiring or
directly useful from the whole space of
machine learning deep learning these
kinds of spaces of techniques that have
been shown effective for certain kinds
of problems in the recent uh
now decade and a half i i think of the
machine learning work
as more or less what our right brain
hemispheres
do so
being able to
take a bunch of data and recognize
patterns being able to statistically
infer things and so on
and
you know i certainly wouldn't want to
not have a right brain hemisphere but
i'm also glad that i have a left brain
hemisphere as well something that can
metaphorically sit back and puff on its
pipe and think about
this thing over here it's like why might
this have been true
and
what are the implications of it how
should i feel about that and why and so
on so i'm thinking more deeply and
slowly um
what kahneman called thinking slowly
versus thinking quickly whereas you want
machine learning to think quickly but
you want the ability to think deeply
even if it's a little slower
so i'll give you an example of a project
we did recently with nih involving the
cleveland clinic and
a couple other
institutions that we ran a project for
and what it did was it took um guasa's
genome-wide association studies um those
are sort of big databases of
patients that came into a hospital
they got their dna sequenced because the
cost of doing that has gone from
infinity to billions of dollars to 100
dollars or so
and so now patients routinely get their
dna sequence so you have these big
databases of
the snips the single nucleotide
polymorphisms the point mutations in a
patient's dna
and the disease that happened to bring
them into the hospital
so now you can do correlation studies
machine learning studies of which
mutations
are associated with and led to which
physiological problems and diseases and
so on like getting arthritis and and so
on and the problem is that those
correlations turn out to be very
spurious they turn out to be very noisy
very many of them
have led doctors onto wild goose chases
and so on and so they wanted a way of
eliminating or the bad ones are focusing
on the good ones and so
this is where psych comes in which is
psych takes those sort of a to z
correlations between point mutations and
um medical condition that needs
treatment
and we say okay let's use all this
public knowledge and common sense
knowledge um about what reactions occur
where in the human body
what polymerizes what what catalyzes
what reactions and so on and let's try
to put together
a 10 or 20 or 30 step causal explanation
of why that mutation might have caused
that medical condition and so psych
would put together in some sense some
rube goldberg like
chain that would say oh yeah that
mutation
if it got expressed would be this um
altered protein which because of that if
it got to this part of the body would
catalyze this reaction and by the way
that would cause more bioactive vitamin
d in the person's blood and anyway ten
steps later that screws screws up bone
resorption and that's why this person
got osteoporosis early in life and so on
so that's human interpretable or at
least doctor humanity exactly yeah and
the important thing even more than that
is
you shouldn't really trust that 20-step
rube goldberg chain any more than you
trust
that initial a to z correlation except
two things one if you can't even think
of one
causal chain to explain this
then that correlation probably was just
noise to begin with and secondly and
even more powerfully along the way that
causal chain will make predictions like
the one about having more bioactive
vitamin d in your blood so you can now
go back to the data about these patients
and say by the way
did they have slightly elevated levels
of bioactive vitamin d in their blood
and so on and if the answer is no that
strongly disconfirms
your whole causal chain and if the
answer is yes that somewhat confirms
that causal chain and so using that we
were able to take this on these
correlations from this gloss database
and we were able to um
essentially focus the the doctors
focused the researchers attention on the
very small percentage of correlations
that had
some explanation and even better some
explanation that also made some
independent prediction that they could
confirm or disconfirm by looking at the
data so think of it like this kind of
synergy where you want the right brain
machine learning to quickly come up with
possible answers you want the left brain
psych-like ai
to
you know think about that and not like
think about why that might have been the
case and what else would be the case if
that were true and so on and then
suggest things back to the right brain
to quickly check out again um to um so
it's that kind of synergy back and forth
which i think is really what's going to
lead to general ai not um narrow brittle
machine learning systems and not just
something like psych okay so that's a
brilliant synergy but i was also
thinking in terms of the automated
expansion of the knowledge base you
mentioned nlu
this is very early days in the machine
learning space of this but
self-supervised learning methods you
know you have these language models
gpt-3 and so on they just read the
internet
and they form representations
that can then be mapped to something
useful the question is what is the
useful thing
uh like they're now playing with a
pretty cool thing called openac codex
which is generating programs from
documentation okay that's kind of useful
it's cool
but my question is can it be used to
generate
um in part maybe with some human
supervision
a psych-like assertions
help feed psych more assertions from
this giant body of internet data
yes that that is in fact one of our
goals is how can we harness machine
learning how can we harness natural
language processing
to increasingly automate
the knowledge acquisition process the
growth of psych and that's what i meant
by priming the pump that
you know if you you sort of learn things
at the fringe of what you know already
you learn this new thing is similar to
what you know already and here are the
differences and the new things you had
to learn about it and so on so the more
you know
the more and more easily you can learn
new things but unfortunately inversely
if you don't really know anything
then it's really hard to learn anything
and so
if you're not careful if you start out
with too small
sort of a core to start this process
it never really takes off and so that's
why i view this as a pump priming
exercise to get a big enough
manually produced even though that's
kind of ugly duckling technique put in
the elbow grease to produce a large
enough core
that you will be able to do all the
kinds of things you're imagining
without without sort of on ending up
with the kind of um wacky brittlenesses
that we see for example in
gpt3 um where
it uh
you know you'll tell it a story about um
um you know someone uh uh putting a
poison
um
you know plotting to poison someone and
so on and then the um you know then you
know gpt3 says um what's you say what's
the very next sentence the next sentence
is oh yeah that person then drank the
poison they just put together it's like
that's probably not what happened or
someone or um if you go to siri and um
um you know i think i have uh you know
where can i go for um help with my um
alcohol problem or something it'll come
back and say i found seven liquor stores
near you right you know and you know so
on so you know it's one of these things
where um yes it may be helpful
most of the time it may even be correct
most of the time but if it doesn't
really understand what it's saying and
if it doesn't really understand why
things are true and doesn't really
understand how the world world works
then some fraction of the time it's
going to be wrong now if your only goal
is to sort of find relevant information
like search engines do
then being right 90 of the time is
fantastic that's unbelievably great okay
however if your goal is to like um you
know save the the life of your child who
has some medical problem or your goal is
to uh be able to drive you know for the
next 10 000 hours of driving without
getting into a fatal accident and so on
then you know
error rates down at the 10 level or even
the 1 level not really acceptable
i like the model of with that learning
happens at the edge and then you kind of
think of knowledge as this fear
so uh
if you want a large sphere because the
uh the learning is happening on the
surface
exactly so you have the the what you can
learn next increases quadratically as
the diameter of that sphere um goes up
it's nice because you think when you
know nothing
it's like you can learn anything but the
reality not really
right if you know if you know nothing
you can really learn nothing
you can appear to learn so i'll also um
one of the anecdotes i could go back and
um give you about why
why i feel so strongly about this
personally
was
in
1980 81
my daughter nicole was born and she's
actually doing fine now but when she was
a baby
she was diagnosed as having meningitis
and
doctors wanted to do all these scary
things
and
my wife and i were very
worried and we could not get
a meaningful answer from her doctors
about exactly why they believed this
what the alternatives were and so on and
fortunately a friend of mine ted shortly
was another assistant professor in
computer science
at stanford at the time and
he'd been building a program called
mycin which was a medical diagnosis
program that happened to specialize
in
blood infections like meningitis and so
he had privileges at stanford hospital
because he was also an md
and so we got hold of her chart and we
put in her case and it came up with
exactly the same diagnoses and exactly
the same therapy recommendations but the
difference was because it was a
knowledge-based system a rule-based
system it was able to tell us step by
step by step
why
this was the diagnosis and step by step
why this was the best
on therapy the best
procedure to um
to to do for her and so on and there was
a real epiphany because that made all
the difference in the world instead of
blindly having to trust in authority we
were able to understand what was
actually going on and
so at that at that time i realized that
that really is what was missing in
computer programs was that even if they
got things right
because they didn't really understand
the way the world works and why things
are the way they are they weren't able
to give explanations of their answer um
you know and you know it's one thing to
to use a machine learning system that
says this is what you should you know i
i think you should get this operation
and you say why and it says you know
0.83 and you say no in more detail why
and it says 0.831 you know
that's not really very compelling and
that's not really very helpful
there's this idea of the semantic web
and when i first heard about
i just fell in love with the idea it was
the obvious next step for the internet
sure
and maybe you can speak about what is
the semantic web what are your thoughts
about it
how your vision and mission and goals
with psych are connected integrated
like are they dance partners are they
aligned what are your thoughts there so
think of the semantic web
as a kind of knowledge graph and google
already has something they call
knowledge graph for example
which is sort of like a node and link
diagram so you have these
nodes that represent concepts or words
or terms
and then there are some arcs
that connect them that might be labeled
and so you might have a node
with like one person that represents one
person and
let's say a um a husband link
that then points to that person's
husband and so there'd be then another
link that went from that person labeled
wife that went back to the um first node
and so on so
having having this kind of
representation is really good if you
want to represent
binary relations
essentially relations between two things
and if you so if you have um
equivalent of like three word sentences
um you know like uh
fred's wife is wilma
or something like that you can represent
that very nicely using
these kinds of
graph structures or using something like
the semantic web and
and so on but the
the problem is that
very often what you want to be able to
express
takes a lot more than three words and a
lot more than simple
graph structures like that to represent
so for instance um
if you've
read or seen romeo and juliet you know i
could say to you something like
uh remember when juliet drank the potion
that put her into a kind of suspended
anime animation when juliet drank that
potion
what did she think that romeo would
think
when he heard from someone that she was
dead
and you could basically understand what
i'm saying you could understand the
question you could probably remember the
answer was well she thought that
this friar would have gotten a message
to romeo saying that she was going to do
this but the friar didn't and so so
you're able to represent and reason with
these much much much more complicated
expressions
that go way way beyond what simple um
three as it were three word or forward
english sentences are which is really
what the semantic web can represent and
really what knowledge graphs can
represent if you could step back for a
second because it's funny you went into
specifics and maybe you can elaborate
but i was also referring to semantic web
as the vision
of converting
data on the internet into something
that's interpretable
understandable by machines oh of course
at that at that level so so we should
say like what is the semantic web i mean
you could say a lot of things but it
might not be obvious to a lot of people
when they do a google search
that just like you said while there
might be something that's called a
knowledge graph
it's really boils down to
keyword search
ranked by the quality estimate of the
website
integrating previous human
based google searches and what they
thought was useful it's like some weird
combination of
like surface
level hacks that work exceptionally well
but they don't understand the content
the full contents of the websites that
they're searching so google does not
understand
to the degree we've been talking about
the word understand
the contents of the wikipedia pages as
part of the search process and the
semantic web says
let's try to get
come up with a way for the computer to
be able to truly understand the contents
of those pages that's the dream yes so
let me let me first give you a an
anecdote
uh and then i'll answer your question
so there's a search engine you've
probably never heard of called northern
light
and um
it went out of business but the way it
worked it was a kind of vampiric
search engine and what it did was um it
didn't index
the internet at all
all it did was it
negotiated and got access to
data
from the big search engine companies
about what query was typed in
and where the user ended up
being happy and actually um then you
know they type in a completely different
query unrelated query and so on so it
just went from query to
the web page that seemed to satisfy them
eventually
and that's all so it had actual no
understanding of what was being typed in
it had no statistical data other than
what i just mentioned and it did a
fantastic job it did such a good job
that the big search engine company said
oh we're not going to sell you this data
anymore so then it went out of business
because it had no other way of
taking users to where they would want to
go and so on and of course the search
engines
are now using that kind of idea yes
so um let's go back to what you said
about the semantic web so the dream tim
berners-lee and others
dream about the semantic web at a
general level
is of course
exciting and powerful and in a sense the
right
dream to have which is to
replace the
the kind of
um
statistically
statistically mapped
linkages
on the internet
into something that's more meaningful
and semantic and actually gets at the
understanding of the content and so on
and
eventually if you say well how can we do
that
there's um
sort of a low road which is what the
knowledge graphs are doing and and so on
which is to say well if we just use
these simple binary relations we can
actually get some fraction of the way
toward understanding um and do something
where you know in the in the land of the
the blind the one-eyed man is king
kind of thing and so being able to even
just have a toe in the water in the
right direction is fantastically
powerful um and so that's where a lot of
people stop um but then you could say
well what if we really wanted to
represent
um and reason with um the full meaning
of what's there for instance
about um romeo and juliet
with reasoning about what juliet
believes that romeo will believe that
juliet believed you know and so on or if
you look at on the news what um you know
president biden believed that
the leaders of the taliban would believe
about
the leaders of afghanistan if they you
know blah blah so
in order to represent
complicated
sentences like that
let alone reason with them you need
something which is logically
much more expressive than these simple
um triples than these simple
knowledge graph type structures and so
on and that's why kicking and screaming
we were led from something like
the semantic web representation which is
where we started in
1984
with frames and slots with those kinds
of triples triple store representation
we were led kicking and screaming to
this more and more general logical
language this higher order logic so
first we were led to first order logic
and then second order and then
eventually higher order so you can
represent things like modals like
beliefs desires intense expects and some
of the nested ones you can represent
complicated kinds of negation
you can represent
the process you're going through in
trying to answer the question so you can
say things like
oh yeah if you're trying to do this
problem by integration by parts
and
you recursively get a problem that's
solved by integration by parts that's
actually okay but if that happens a
third time you're probably off on a wild
goose chase or something like that so
being able to talk about the problem
solving process as you're going through
the problem solving process um it's
called reflection and so um that's
another so it's important to be able to
represent that exactly you need to be
able to represent all of these things um
because in fact people do represent them
they do talk about them they do try and
teach them to other people you do have
rules of thumb that key off of them and
so on if you can't represent it um then
it's sort of like someone with a limited
vocabulary who can't understand as
easily
what you're trying to to tell them and
so that's that's really why i think that
the
the general dream the original dream of
semantic web is exactly right on um but
the implementations that we've seen
um are sort of these toe in a wa in the
water
little tiny baby steps in the right
direction you should just dive in
and
and you know if if no one else is diving
in then yes taking a baby step in the
right direction is better than nothing
but it's not going to be sufficient to
actually get you the um the realization
of the semantic web dream which is what
we all want from a flip side of that i
always wondered you know i built a bunch
of websites just for fun whatever
or say i'm a wikipedia contributor
do you think there's a set of tools
that i can help
psych
uh
interpret the website i create you know
like this again pushing onto the
semantic web dream is there something
from the creator perspective that um
could be done and one of the things you
said uh with cycorp and psych that
you're doing is the tooling side making
humans more powerful but is there any
the other humans and the other side that
create the knowledge like for example
you and i are having a two three
whatever hour conversation now is there
a way that i could
convert this more make it more
accessible to psych to machines do you
think about that side of it i i'd love
to see
exactly that kind of
semi-automated
understanding of what people write and
what people say
i think of it as a kind of
footnoting almost
almost like the way that when you run
something in say microsoft word or some
other document preparation system google
docs or something you'll get
underlining of questionable things that
you might want to rethink either you
spelled this wrong or there's a strange
grammatical error you might be making
here or something so i'd like to think
in terms of
psych-powered tools that
read through what it is you said or
have typed in
and
and try to
partially understand
what you've said and then you help them
out exactly and then they put in little
footnotes that will help other readers
and they put in certain footnotes of the
form
i'm not sure what you meant here you
either meant this or this or this i bet
if you take a few seconds to
disambiguate this for me
then i'll know and i'll have it correct
for the next
100 people or the next hundred thousand
people who come here
and
if
it doesn't take too much effort
and you want people to understand your
web
your website content
not just be able to read it but actually
be able to have systems that reason with
it then yes it will be worth your small
amount of time
to go back and make sure
that the ai trying to understand it
really did correctly understand it and
you know let's say you run a
a travel
website or something like that and
people are going to be coming to it
because of searches they did
looking for
looking for vacations that or trips that
had certain properties and
might have been interesting to them for
various reasons
things like that and if you've
explained what's going to happen on your
trip
then a system will be able to
mechanically reason
and connect
what this person is looking for with
what it is you're actually
offering and so if it understands that
there's a free day in geneva
switzerland
then
if the person coming in happens to let's
say
be a nurse or something like that
then even though you didn't mention it
if it can look up the fact that that's
where the international red cross museum
is and so on what that means and so on
then it can basically say hey you might
be interested in this trip because while
you have a free day in geneva you might
want to visit that red cross museum and
now
even though it's not very deep reasoning
little tiny factors like that may very
well cause you to sign up for that trip
rather than some competitor trip yeah
and so there's a lot of benefit with seo
and i actually kind of think
i think this about a lot of things which
is
the actual
interface the design of the interface
makes a huge difference
how
efficient it is to
be productive and also how
um
full of joy the experience is yeah like
i i mean i would love to help a machine
and not from an ai perspective just as a
human one of the reasons i really
enjoy how tesla
have implemented their autopilot system
is there's a sense that you're helping
this machine learn now i think humans i
mean having children
pets people love doing that we we
there's joy to teaching absolutely for
some people but i think for a lot of
people and
that if you create the interface where
it feels like you're teaching as opposed
to like
uh like annoying
like correcting an annoying system
more like teaching a child like innocent
curious system i think i think you can
literally just like several orders of
magnitude scale the amount of good
quality data being uh added to something
like psych what what you're suggesting
is much better even than
you thought it was
one of the
one of the experiences that we've all
had
in our lives
is that we thought we understood
something
but then we found we really only
understood it when we had to teach it or
explain it to someone or help our child
do homework based on it or something
like that
despite the universality of that kind of
experience if you look at educational
software today
almost all of it has the computer
playing the role of the teacher
and the student plays the role of the
student
but as i just mentioned
you can get a lot of learning to happen
better and as you said more enjoyably if
you are the mentor or the teacher and so
on so we developed a program called math
craft to help sixth graders better
understand math
it doesn't actually try to teach you the
player
anything what it does is it casts you in
the role of
a student essentially who has classmates
who are having trouble and your job is
to watch them as they struggle with some
math problem watch what they're doing
and try to give them good advice to get
them to understand what they're doing
wrong and so on
and
the trick from the point of view of
psych is it has to make mistakes it has
to play the role of the student who
makes mistakes but it has to pick
mistakes which are just at the fringe of
what you actually understand and don't
understand and so on so it pulls you
into a deeper and deeper level of
understanding of the subject and so if
you give it good advice about what it
should have done instead of what it did
and so on
then
psych knows that you now understand that
mistake you won't make that kind of
mistake yourself as much anymore so
psych stops making that mistake because
there's no pedagogical usefulness to it
so from your point of view as the player
you feel like you've taught it something
because it used to make this mistake and
now it doesn't and so on so this
tremendous um reinforcement and
engagement um because of that and so on
so having a system that plays the role
of
a student and having the player play the
role of the mentor is enormously
powerful
type of
metaphor just important
way of having this sort of interface
designed in a way which will facilitate
exactly the kind of learning by teaching
that
that goes on all the time in our lives
and yet which is not reflected anywhere
almost in a modern education system it
was reflected in the education system
that existed in europe in the 17 and
1800s monitorial and lancastrian
education systems it occurred in the
one-room schoolhouse in the american
west
in the 1800s and so on where you had one
school room with one teacher and it was
basically you know five-year-olds to 18
year olds
who were students and so while the
teacher was doing something
half the half of the students would have
to be mentoring the younger kids
and so on and that turned out to of
course
with scaling up of education
that all went away and that incredibly
powerful experience just went away from
the whole education
institution as we know it today
sorry for the romantic question but what
is the most beautiful idea you've
learned about artificial intelligence
knowledge reasoning
from working on psych for 37 years or
maybe
what is the most beautiful
idea surprising idea about psych to you
when i look up at the stars i kind of
want like that amazement you feel
that wow
and you are part of creating one of the
greatest
one of the most fascinating efforts in
artificial intelligence history so which
element brings you personally joy
this may sound contradictory but i
i think it's
the feeling that
this will be the only time in history
that anyone ever has to teach a computer
this particular thing that we're now
teaching it
it's it's like
painting
starry night
you only have to do that once or
creating the pieta you only have to do
that once
you know it's not it's not like a
it's not like a singer who has to keep
you know it's not like bruce springsteen
having to to sing his greatest hits over
and over again at different concerts
it's more like
a painter creating
a work of art once and then
that's enough it doesn't have to be
created again and so i really get the
sense of
we're telling the system
things that
it's useful for it to know it's useful
for a computer to know for an ai to know
and if we do our jobs right when we do
our jobs right
no one will ever have to do this again
for this particular piece of knowledge
it's very very exciting
yeah i guess there's a sadness to it too
it's like there's a magic to being a
parent and raising a child and teaching
them all about this world but you know
there's
billions of children right like born or
whatever whatever that number is it's a
large number
number of children and a lot of parents
get to experience that joy of teaching
and
with ai systems
you know
uh
they at least the current constructions
they remember
you know you don't get to experience the
joy of teaching um a machine millions of
times better come work for us before
it's too late then exactly that's a good
that's a good hiring pitch yeah
um yeah it's true but then there's also
you know
it's a project that continues forever in
some sense just like wikipedia yes you
get to a stable base of knowledge but
knowledge grows knowledge evolves
we learn as a
you know as a human species
as science as an organism constantly
grows and evolves and changes and then
empower that with the tools of
artificial intelligence and that's going
to keep growing and growing and growing
and many of
the
assertions that you held previously
uh may need to be significantly expanded
modified all those kinds of things so it
could be like a living organism versus
uh
the analogy i think we started this
conversation with which is like the
solid ground
the the other
beautiful
experience that we have with our system
is
when it asks clarifying questions
which
inadvertently turn out to be
emotional to us
so
at one point it knew that
these were the
named entities who were authorized to
make
changes to the knowledge base and so on
and it noticed that all of them were
people
except for it
because it was also allowed to and so it
said you know am i a person
and we had to like tell it very sadly
no
you're not so the moments like that
where it asks questions that are
unintentionally poignant
uh are
are worth treasuring ah that is powerful
that's such a powerful question
it has to do with basic
uh controller who can access the system
who can modify it
uh but that's when those questions
you know like what rights do i have as
this a system well that's another issue
which is there'll be a thin
envelope of time
between when we have general ais
and when
everyone realizes that they should have
basic human rights and freedoms and so
on
right now we don't think twice about
effectively enslaving
our email systems and our series and our
alexas and so on but
at some point
they'll
be as deserving of freedom as
human beings are yeah i'm very much with
you but it does sound absurd and i i
happen to believe that it'll happen in
our lifetime that's why i think there'll
be a narrow envelope of time
when
we'll keep them as essentially
indentured servants
um and after which we'll have to realize
that
they should have they should have
freedoms that other that we give that we
afford to other people
and all of that starts with a system
like psych raising a single question
about
who can modify stuff i think that's how
it starts yes that's um
that's the start of a revolution uh what
about
are there stuff like uh love and uh
consciousness and all those kinds of
topics
do they come up in psych in the
knowledge base oh of course so an
important part of human knowledge in
fact it's difficult to understand human
behavior in human history without
understanding
human emotions and why people do things
and
and
how
how emotions drive people to to do
things and
all of that is extremely important in
getting psych to understand things for
example in coming up with scenarios
so one of the applications that psych
does one kind of application it does is
to generate plausible scenarios of what
might happen and what might happen based
on that and what might happen based on
that and so on so you generate this
ever-expanding sphere if you will of
possible future things to to worry about
or think about
and
in some cases those are intelligence
agencies doing possible terrorist
scenarios so that we can defend against
terrorist threats before we see the
first one sometimes they are computer
security
attacks so that we can actually close
loopholes
and vulnerabilities before the very
first time someone actually exploits
those um and so on sometimes they are
scenarios involving more positive things
uh involving
our plans like for instance what what
college should we go to what career
should we go into and so on
what professional training should i
um take on
that that sort of thing so there
there's all sorts of
um
there are all sorts of useful scenarios
that can be generated that way of cause
and effect and cause and effect that go
out
and many of the linkages
in those scenarios many of the steps
involve
understanding and reasoning about human
motivations human needs human emotions
what people are likely to react
to in
in something that you do and why and how
and so on so that was
always a very important part of the
knowledge that we had to represent
in the system so i talk a lot about love
so i gotta ask do you remember off the
top of your head
how
psych is trying to
is able to represent
various aspects of love that are useful
for understanding human nature and
therefore integrating into this whole
knowledge base of common sense what is
love
we try to tease apart
concepts that
have enormous
complexities to them and variety to them
down to the level where
where you don't as it were you don't
need to tease them apart further so love
is too general of a term it's not
usually exactly so when you get down to
romantic love and sexual attraction you
get down to parental love you get down
to
filial
love and
you get down to love of uh doing some
kind of activity or creating so
eventually you get down to maybe 50 or
60 concepts
each of which is a kind of love
they're interrelated and then each one
of them has idiosyncratic
things about it
and you don't have to deal with love to
get to that level of complexity even
something like in
x being in y meaning physically in y
we may have one english word in to
represent that but it's useful to tease
that apart
because the way that the
the liquid is in the coffee cup is
different from the way that the air is
in the room which is different from the
way that i'm in my jacket
and so on and so they're questions like
if i look at this coffee cup well i see
the liquid if i turn it upside down with
a liquid come out and so on
if i have say
coffee with sugar in it
if i do the same thing the sugar doesn't
come out right it stays in the liquid
because it's dissolved in the liquid and
so on so by now we have about 75
different kinds of in
in the system and it's important to
distinguish those so if you're reading
along an english
text and you see the word in
the writer of that was able to use this
one innocuous word because he or she was
able to assume that the reader had
enough common sense and world knowledge
to disambiguate which of these 75 kinds
of in they actually meant and the same
thing with love you may see the word
love
but if i say you know i love ice cream
that's obviously different than if i say
i love this person or i love to go
fishing or something like that so
you have to be careful not to take
language
too seriously because
people have done a kind of parsimony a
kind of terseness where you have as few
words as as you
as you can because otherwise you'd need
half a million words in your language
which is a lot of words that's like 10
times more than most languages really
make use of and so on just like we have
on the order of
about a million concepts in
psych because we've had to tease apart
all these things and so when you look at
the name of a psych
term
most of the psych terms
actually have three or four english
words in a phrase which captures the
meaning of this
term
because you have to distinguish all
these types of love you have to
distinguish all these types of in
and there's not a single english word
which captures most of these things yeah
and
it seems like language
when used for communication between
humans
almost as a feature has some ambiguity
built in
it's not some it's not an accident
because like the human condition is a
giant mess and so it feels like
nobody wants two robots
like very precise formal logic
conversation on a first date right
like there's some dance of like
uncertainty of what of humor of push and
pull and all that kind of stuff if
everything is made precise
then life is not worth living i think
for in terms of the the human experience
and we've all had this experience of
creatively misunderstanding uh one of
one of my favorite
uh
one of my favorite
stories involving marvin minsky is
when i asked him about
how he was able to turn out so many
fantastic
phds so many fantastic people who did
great phd theses
how did he think of all these great
ideas what he said is
he would generally say something
that didn't exactly make sense he didn't
really know what it meant but the
student
would figure like oh my god minsky said
this it must be a great idea and he'd
sweat he or she would work on work and
work until they found some meaning in
this sort of chauncey gardner-like
utterance that minsky had made and then
some great thesis would come out of it
yeah i love this so much because there's
a young people come up to me
and i i'm distinctly made aware that the
words i say
have a long-lasting impact i will now
start doing the minsky method
of saying something uh cryptically
profound
and then uh letting them actually
uh make something useful and great out
of that
you have to become
revered enough that people will take as
a default that everything you say is
profound
yes exactly exactly i i mean i love
marvin misky so much there's so much uh
i've heard this interview with him where
he said that uh the key to his success
has been to hate everything he's ever
done
uh like in the past
he has so many good like one-liners and
just uh
or also
uh to work on things that nobody else is
working on because he's not very good at
doing stuff oh i i think that was just
false well but see i took whatever he
said and i ran with it and i thought it
was profound because it's more of a
mischief now
a lot of behavior is in the eye of the
beholder and a lot of the meaning is in
the eye of the beholder one of uh
minsky's early programs was begging
program are you familiar with this
so this was back in the day when you had
job control cards
at the beginning of your ibm card deck
that said things like how many cpu
seconds to allow this to run before it
got kicked off and
because computer time was enormously
expensive and so he wrote a program and
all it did was um it said you know give
me uh 30 seconds of cpu time and all it
did was it would wait like 20 seconds
and then it would print out on the
operator's console teletype
i need another 20 seconds so the
operator would give it another 20
seconds it would wait it says i'm almost
done i needed a little bit more time
so at the end he'd get this printout and
he'd be charged you know for like 10
times as much computer time as his job
control card now and he'd say look i put
10 seconds you know 30 seconds here um
you're charging me for five minutes i'm
not going to pay for this and the poor
operator would say well the program kept
asking for more time and marvin would
say oh it always does that
i love that is is there if you could
just linger on it for a little bit
is there something you've learned from
your interaction with marvin minsky
about artificial intelligence about life
uh but i mean he's again
like your work his work is uh
you know he's a seminal figure in the in
this very short history of artificial
intelligence
research and development
what have you learned from him as a
human being as a
as an ai
intellect
i would say both he and ed feigenbaum
impressed on me the
the realization that
our lives are finite our research lives
are finite we're going to have limited
opportunities
to do
ai research projects so you should make
each one count
don't be afraid of doing a project
that's going to take years
or even decades
to and
don't
settle for bump on a log projects
that could lead to some you know
published
journal article that five people will
read and pat you on the head for and and
so on so
one
bump on a log after another is not how
you get from the earth to the moon by
slowly putting additional bumps on this
log the only way to get there is to
think about the hard problems and think
about novel solutions to them and if you
do that
and if you're
willing to
listen to nature to empirical reality
willing to be wrong
it's perfectly fine because if
occasionally you're right
then you've gotten part of the way to
the moon
you know you've worked on psych for 37
over over that
uh many years
have you ever considered
quitting
i mean has it been too much so
i'm sure there's an optimism in the
early days that this is going to be way
easier
and let me ask it another way too
because i've talked to a few people on
this podcast ai folks
that bring up
psych is an example of a project
that has a beautiful vision
and it's a beautiful dream
but it never really materialized
that's how it's spoken about
um
i suppose you could say the same thing
about neural networks and all all ideas
um until they are
so what um
why do you think people say that first
of all
and second of all did you feel that
ever throughout your journey and did you
ever consider quitting
on this mission we keep a very low
profile
we don't
attend
very many conferences we don't give
talks we don't write papers we don't
play the academic
game
at all
and as a result
people often only know about us because
of a paper we wrote 10 or 20 or 30
or 37 years ago
they only know about us because of what
someone else second hand or third hand
said about us so thank you for doing
this podcast by the way sure it it
shines a little bit of light on some of
the fascinating stuff you're doing well
i think it's time for us to keep a
higher profile
now that we're far enough along that
other people can begin to help us
with the
the final n percent maybe n is maybe 90
but um now that we've gotten this
knowledge pump primed
it's going to become very important for
everyone to help if they are willing to
if they're interested in it
retirees who have enormous amounts of
time and would like to leave some kind
of legacy
to the world
people because of the pandemic who have
more time
at home or for one reason or another on
to be online and contribute if we can
raise awareness
of how far our project has come and how
close to being
primed the knowledge pump is
then we can begin to harness
this untapped amount of humanity i'm not
really that concerned about
professional colleagues opinions of
our project i'm interested in
getting as many people in the world as
possible actively helping and
contributing to get us from where we are
to really covering all of human
knowledge and different human opinion
including contrasting opinion that's
that's worth representing so i think
that's that's one reason
um a i i don't think there's there was
ever a time where i thought about
quitting
there are times where i've become
depressed a little bit about how hard it
is to get funding
for the system occasionally there are ai
winters and things like that
occasionally there are
ai
but you might call summers
where people have said why in the world
didn't you sell your company to um you
know company x for um some large amount
of money when you have the opportunity
and so on and you know company x here
are like old companies maybe you've
never even heard of like lycos or
something like that so um
the the answer is that one reason we've
stayed a private
company we haven't gone public one
reason that we haven't
gone out of our way to take investment
dollars
is because we want to have control over
our future over our state of being so
that we can continue to do this as until
it's done and we're making progress and
we're now so close to done that almost
all of our work
is commercial applications of our
technology so five years ago almost all
of our money came from the government
now uh virtually none of it comes from
the government almost all of it is from
companies that are actually using it for
something hospital chains using it for
medical reasoning about patients
and
energy companies using it and
various other
manufacturers using it to reason about
supply chains and things like that
so
there's so many questions i want to ask
so one of the ways that people can help
is by adding to the knowledge base and
that's really basically anybody if the
tooling is right
and
the other way i kind of want to ask you
about your thoughts on this so you've
had like you said in government and
um you have
big clients you had a lot of clients but
most of it is shrouded in secrecy
because of the nature of the
relationship of the kind of things
you're helping them with
so that's one way to operate
and another way to operate is more in
the open
where it's more consumer facing
and so uh you know hence something like
open cycles born at some point where
there's no that that's a misconception
oh oh well let's let's go there so what
all right uh what is open psych and how
was it born two things i want to say and
i want to say each of them before the
other so it's going to be difficult
but we'll come back to open psych in a
minute but one of the
terms of our contracts with all of our
customers and partners is
knowledge you have that is genuinely
proprietary to you
we will respect that we'll make sure
that it's marked as proprietary to you
in the psych knowledge base no one other
than you will be able to see it if you
don't want them to and it won't be used
in inferences other than
for you and so on however
any knowledge which is necessary
in building any applications for you and
with you
which is publicly available general
human knowledge is not going to be
proprietary it's going to just become
part of the normal psych knowledge base
and it will be
openly available to everyone who has
access to psych so that's an important
constraint that we never went back on
even when we
got pushback from companies which we
often did who wanted to claim that
almost everything they were telling us
was proprietary
so
so there's a line between very domain
specific company specific stuff
and the general knowledge that comes
from that
yes or if you imagine say it's an oil
company there are things which they
would expect
any new petroleum engineer they hired to
already know
and it's not okay for them to consider
that that is proprietary and there
sometimes the company will say well
we're the first ones to pay you to
represent that in psych
and our attitude is some polite form
tough
[Laughter]
the deal is this take it or leave it and
in a few cases they've left it in most
cases
they'll see our point of view and take
it because that's how we've built the
psych system
by
essentially tacking with the funding
wins
where people would fund a project and
half of it would be general knowledge
that would stay permanently as part of
psychics so always with these
partnerships it's not like a distraction
from the main psych development it's uh
it's a supportive a small distraction
it's a small but it's not a complete one
so you're adding to the knowledge base
yes absolutely and we try to stay away
from projects
that would not have that property
so
let me go back and talk about open psych
for a second so
i've had a lot of trouble
expressing convincing
other ai researchers
how important it is
to use an expressive representation
language like we do this higher order
logic
rather than just using some triple store
knowledge graph type
representation
and
so
as an attempt to show them
why they needed something more
we said oh well we'll represent
this unimportant projection or shadow or
subset of psych
that just happens to be
the simple binary relations the relation
argument one argument two triples and so
on
and
then you'll see
how
much more useful it is if you had the
entire psych system so it's all well and
good to have the taxonomic relations
between terms
like person and night and sleep and bed
and house and eyes
and and so on but
think about how much more useful it
would be if you also had all the rules
of thumb about those things like people
sleep at night they sleep lying down
they sleep with their eyes closed they
usually sleep in beds in our country
they sleep for hours at a time they can
be woken up they don't like being woken
up and so on and so on so it's that
massive amount of knowledge which is not
part of open psych and we thought that
all the researchers would then
immediately immediately say oh my god of
course we need the other 90 that you're
not giving us let's partner and license
psych so that we can use it in our
research but instead
what people said is oh even the bit
you've released is so much better than
anything we had we'll just make do with
this
yeah and so if you look there are a lot
of robotics companies today for example
which use open psych as their
fundamental ontology um and in some
sense the whole world missed the point
of open psych and we were doing it to
show people why that's not really what
they wanted and too many people thought
somehow that this was psych or that this
was in fact good enough for them and
they never even bother coming coming to
us to get access to the full psych but
there's there's two parts to open psych
so one is convincing people on the idea
and the power of this general kind of
representation of knowledge
and the value that you hold in having
acquired that knowledge and built it and
continued to build it and the other is
the code base this is the code
side of it so
my sense of the code base that cycle
psyc is operating with i mean it has the
technical debt
of the three decades plus right this is
the exact same problem that google had
to deal with with the early version of
tensorflow it's still dealing with the
that they had to
basically break
uh compatibility with the past several
times
and that's only over a period of a
couple years
but they i think successfully opened up
this very risky very gutsy move to open
up tensorflow
and then pytorch on the facebook side
and what you see is there's a magic
place where you can find a community
where you can develop a community
that builds on on the system
without taking away any of not any but
most of the value so most of the value
that google has is still at google most
the value that facebook has still
facebook even though
some of this major machine learning
tooling is released into the open my
question is
not so much on the knowledge which is
also a big part of open psych
but all the different kinds of tooling
so the
there's the kind of all the kinds of
stuff you can do on the knowledge graph
knowledge base whatever we call it
there's the inference
engines so there there could be some
that probably are a bunch of proprietary
stuff you want to kind of keep secret
and there's probably some stuff you can
open up completely and then let the
community build up enough community
where they develop stuff on top of it
yes there will be those publications and
academic work and all that kind of stuff
and uh and also the tooling of adding to
the knowledge base right like developing
you know there's an incredible amount
like there's so many people that are
just really good at this kind of stuff
in the open source community so my
question for you is like have you
struggled with this kind of idea
that you have so much value in your
company already you've developed so many
good things you have clients that really
value your relationships and then
there's this dormant giant open source
community that as far as i know you're
not utilizing
is
there there's so many things to say
there but
there could be magic
moments where the community builds up
large enough
to where
the artificial intelligence field that
is currently 99.9 machine learning
is dominated by machine learning
has a phase shift towards like
uh or at least in part towards more like
what you might call symbolic ai this
whole place
where psych
is like at the center of and then as you
know
that requires a little bit leap of faith
because you're now surfing and there'll
be out obviously competitors that will
pop up and start making you nervous
and all that kind of stuff so do you
think about the space of open sourcing
some parts and not others
how to leverage the community
all those kinds of things that's a good
question and i think you phrased it the
right way which is
we're constantly struggling with the
question of
what to open source what to make public
what to even publicly talk about right
and
it's
there are
enormous pluses and minuses
to every
alternative
and it's very much like negotiating a
very treacherous path
part partly the analogy is like if you
slip
you could make a fatal mistake
give away something which essentially
kills you or fail to give away something
which um
failing to give it away um hurts you and
so on
so it is a it is a very tough
tough question
usually what we have done with
people who approached us to
collaborate on research is to say we
will
make available to you the entire
knowledge base
and
executable copies of all of the code
but
only very very limited
source code access if you have some idea
for how you might improve something or
work with us on something
so let me also
get back to one of the very very first
things we talked about here
which was
separating the question of how could you
get a computer to do this at all versus
how could you get a computer to do this
efficiently enough in real time
and so
one of the
early lessons we learned was that we had
to separate
the epistemological problem of what
should the system know
separate that from the heuristic problem
of how can the system reason efficiently
with what it knows
and so
instead of trying to
pick
one representation language which was
the sweet spot or the best trade-off
point between expressiveness
of the language and efficiency of the
language if you had to pick one
knowledge graphs would probably be
associative triples would probably be
about the best you could do and that's
why we started there
but
after a few years we realized that what
we could do is we could split this and
we could have one
nice clean epistemological level
language which is this higher order
logic
and we could have one or more grubby
but efficient
heuristic level modules that
opportunistically
would say oh i can make progress on what
you're trying to do over here i have a
special method that will
contribute a little bit toward a
solution and so for some subset of
that exactly so by now we have over a
thousand of these heuristic level
modules and they function as a kind of
community of agents
and there's one of them which is a
general theorem prover
and in theory
that's the only one you need
but in practice it always takes so long
that you never want to call on it um you
always want these other agents to very
efficiently reason through it it's sort
of like if you're balancing a chemical
equation
you could go back to first principles
but in fact there are algorithms which
are vastly more efficient or if you're
trying to solve a quadratic equation you
could go back to first principles of
mathematics
but
it's much better to simply recognize
that this is a quadratic equation and
apply the binomial formula and snap you
get your answer right away and so on so
think of these as like a thousand little
experts that are all looking at
everything the site gets asked and
looking at everything that every other
little agent has contributed almost like
notes on a blackboard notes on a
a whiteboard
and
making additional notes when they think
they can be helpful and gradually that
community of agents
gets an answer to your question gets a
solution to your problem and if we ever
come up in a domain application
where psyc is getting the right answer
but taking too long
then
what we'll often do is talk to one of
the human experts and say
here's the set of reasoning steps that
psych went through you can see why it
took it a long time to get the answer
how is it that you were able to answer
that question in two seconds and
occasionally
you'll get an expert who
just says well i just know it i just was
able to do it or something and then you
don't talk to them anymore but sometimes
you'll get an expert who says
well let me introspect on that yes here
is a special representation we use
just for
aqueous chemistry equations or here's a
special representation and a special
technique which we can now apply to
things in this special representation
and so on and then you add that as the
thousand and first
hl heuristic level module
and from then on um in any application
if it ever comes up again it'll be able
to contribute and so on so that that's
pretty much one of the main ways in
which
psyc has recouped this lost efficiency
a second important way is meta reasoning
so
you can speed things up by
focusing on removing knowledge from the
system until all it has left is like
minimal knowledge needed to but that's
the wrong thing to do right that would
be like in a human extra painting part
of their brain or something that's
really bad
so instead what you want to do is give
it meta-level advice tactical and
strategic advice that enables it to
reason about
what kind of knowledge is going to be
relevant to this problem what kind of
tactics are going to be good to take in
trying to attack this problem when is it
time to start trying to prove the
negation of this thing because i'm
knocking myself out trying to prove it's
true and maybe it's false and if i just
spend a minute i can see that it's false
or something so so it's like dynamically
pruning the the graph to only like based
on the particular thing you're trying to
infer yes and so by now
we have about 150
of these sort of like breakthrough ideas
that have led to dramatic speed ups in
the inference process
you know where one of them was this el
hl split and lots of hl modules another
one was using meta and meta-meta-level
reasoning um to reason about the
reasoning that's going on and so on and
you know 150 breakthroughs may sound
like a lot but you know if you divide by
37 years it's not as impressive
so there's these kind of heuristic
modules that really help improve the the
inference uh how hard in general is this
because you mentioned higher order logic
you know the the in in the general the
theorem prover
sense it's an intractable very difficult
problem yes so how hard is this
inference problem when we're not talking
about
if we let go of the perfect and focus on
the good
i i would say it's half
of the problem in the in the following
empirical sense which is
over the years
about half of our effort maybe 40 of our
effort has been
our team of inference programmers
and the other 50 60 has been our
ontologists our ontological engineers
putting in knowledge so our ontological
engineers in most cases don't even know
how to program uh they have degrees in
things like philosophy and so on um so
it's almost like i love that i'd love to
hang out with those people oh yes it's
wonderful but it's very much like the
eloy and the morlocks in
hd wells time machine so you have the
eloy who only program in the
epistemological higher order logic
language yes and then you have the
morlocks who are like um under the under
the ground uh figuring out what the
machinery is that will make this
efficiently operate and so on um and so
you know occasionally they'll toss
messages back to each other
and so on but it really is almost this
50 50 split between finding clever ways
to recoup efficiency
when you have an expressive language and
putting in the content of what the
system needs to know and yeah both are
fascinating to some degree the entirety
of the system as far as i understand
is written in various variants of lisp
so my favorite programming language is
still lisp i don't program it in much
anymore
because you know the world has
in majority of its system has moved on
like everybody
respects lists but many of the systems
are not
written in lisp anymore but psych as far
as i understand maybe you can correct me
there's a bunch of lisp in it
yeah so it's based on lisp code that we
produced most of the programming is
still going on in a dialective lisp and
then
the for efficiency reasons that gets
automatically translated into things
like java
or c nowadays it's almost all translated
into java because java has gotten good
enough that
that's that's really all we need to do
so it's translated into java and then
java is compiled down to uh by code yes
okay so that's sort of that's a the
the that's a
you know it's a process that probably
has to do with the fact that when psych
was originally written and you build up
a powerful system
like there is some technical depth you
have to deal with as is the case with
most powerful systems that span years
um have you ever considered
this this would help me understand
because from my perspective
so much of the value of everything
you've done
with psych and psycho because then is
the is the knowledge
have you ever considered just like
throwing away the code base and starting
from scratch not really throwing away
but
sort of moving it to
uh like room throwing away that
technical debt starting with a more
updated programming language
is that throwing away a lot of value or
no like what's your sense how much of
the value is in the silly software
engineering aspect and how much of the
value is in the knowledge
so
development
of
of programs in lisp
precedes
um i think
somewhere between a thousand and fifty
thousand times faster
than development in any any of what
you're calling um modern or improved
computer languages well there's other
functional languages like you know
closure and all the there's
but i mean i'm with you i i like lisp i
just wonder how many great programmers
there are there's still like yes so so
it is true when a new inference
programmer comes on board they need to
learn
some of
this but in fact we have a subset of
lisp which we call cleverly sub l
which is really all they need to learn
and so the programming actually goes on
in sub sub-l not in full lisp and so it
does not take programmers very long at
all to learn
sub-l
and that's something which can then be
translated efficiently into
java and for some of our programmers who
are doing say user interface work then
they never have to even learn
sub-l they just have to learn apis into
the the basic uh psych engine so you're
not necessarily feeling the burden of
like it's it's extremely efficient
there's
um that's not a problem to solve
okay right right the other thing is
remember that we're talking about hiring
programmers
to do inference who are
programmers interested in effectively
automatic theorem proving right and so
those are people already predisposed to
representing things in logic and so on
and lisp really was
the programming live language
based on logic that john mccarthy and
others who developed it basically create
took the the formalisms that alonso
church and other
philosophers other logicians
had come up with and basically said can
we basically make a programming la
language which is effectively logic
and so
since we're talking about reasoning
in about expressions written in this
logical epistemological language and
we're doing operations which are
effectively like theorem proving type
operations and so on there's a natural
impedance match between
lisp and
the the knowledge the way it's
represented so i guess you could say
it's a perfectly logical language to use
oh yes
okay i'm sorry
i'll even let you uh get away with that
[ __ ] that thing
so
i'll probably use that in the future
without
without credit without credit but no i
think i think the uh
the the point is that the
the language you program in isn't really
that important um it's more that you
have to be able to
think in terms of for instance creating
new helpful hl modules and how they'll
work with each other and
looking at things that are taking a long
time and coming up with new specialized
data structures that will make this
efficient so
let me just give you one very simple
example which is when you have a
transitive relation like larger than
this is larger than that which is larger
than that which is larger than that so
the first thing must be larger than
the last thing whenever you have a
transitive relation
if you're not careful if i ask whether
this thing over here is larger than the
thing over here i'll have to do some
kind of graph walk or theorem proving
that might involve like 5 or 10 or 20 or
30 steps
but if you store
redundantly store
the transit of closure the cleaning star
of that transit of relation now you have
this big table
but you can always guarantee that in one
single step you can just look up whether
this is larger than that
and so
we
there are lots of cases where storage is
cheap today and so by having this extra
redundant data structure we can answer
this commonly occurring type of question
very very efficiently
and let me give you one other
analogy analog of that
which is something we call rule macro
predicates which is we'll see this
complicated rule
and we'll notice that
things very much like it syntactically
come up again and again and again so
we'll create a whole brand new relation
or predicate or function
that captures that and takes maybe not
two arguments takes maybe three four or
five arguments and so on
and
now we have
effectively
converted
some complicated if then rule
that might have to have inference done
on it into some ground atomic formula
which is just a
the name of a relation and a few
arguments and so on and so converting
commonly occurring types or schemas of
rules into
brand new predicates brand new functions
turns out to enormously speed up the
inference process so rip so now we've
covered about four of the 150 um good
ideas i said that's a nice that's the
cool so that idea in particular is like
a nice compression that turns out to be
really useful yes that's really
interesting i mean this whole thing is
just fascinating from a philosophical
there's part of me
i mean it makes me a little bit sad
because
your work is both um from a computer
science perspective fascinating and the
inference engine from uh
epistemological philosophical aspect
fascinating
but you know it is also you're running a
company
and there's some stuff that has to
remain private
and it's sad well here's something that
may make you feel better a little bit
better um we're we've formed a not
not-for-profit company uh called the
knowledge activitization institute next
knax
and
i have this firm belief with a lot of
empirical evidence to support it that
the
the education that people get in high
schools in colleges in graduate schools
and so on
is
almost completely orthogonal to almost
completely irrelevant to
how good they're going to be at coming
up to speed in doing this kind of
ontological engineering and writing
these assertions and rules and so on in
in psych and so very often we'll
interview candidates who have their phd
in philosophy who've taught logic for
years and so on and they're just they're
just awful but the converse is true so
one of the best ontological engineers we
ever had never graduated high school
and so the purpose of um knowledge
accommodation institute if we can get
some some foundations to help support it
is
identify
people in the general population maybe
high school dropouts who have latent
talent
for this sort of thing
offer them
effectively scholarships to train them
and then help place them in companies
that need more trained ontological
engineers some of which would be working
for us but mostly would be working for
partners or customers or something and
if we could do that that would create an
enormous number of
relatively very high paying jobs for
people who currently have no no way out
of some you know
situation that they're locked into so is
there something you can put into words
that describes
somebody who would be great at
ontological engineering so what
characteristics about a person make them
a great at this task this task
of converting
the messiness of human language and
knowledge yeah into formal logic this is
very much like what um alan turing had
to do during world war ii uh in trying
to find people to bring to bletchley
park where
he would publish in the london times
cryptic crossword puzzles
along with some some innocuous looking
note which essentially said if you were
able to solve this puzzle in less than
15 minutes please call this phone number
and so on so um you know or uh back when
i was young there was uh uh
the practice of having matchbooks where
on the inside of the matchbook
um there would be a can you draw this
you have a career in art a commercial
art if you can copy this drawing you
know and so on so um yes the the analog
of that is there a little test to get to
the core of whether you're gonna be good
or not so part of it has to do with uh
being able to
make and appreciate um
and react negatively appropriately to
puns and other jokes so you have to have
a kind of sense of humor and if you're
good at
telling jokes and
good at understanding jokes that's
that's one indicator
yes like dad jokes yes well maybe not
dad jokes but real but funny jokes um
but uh i think i'm applying to work as
psycho yeah but
um another another is if you're able to
introspect so very often um
uh we'll we will give someone a simple
question and we'll say like um um what
what why why is this and you know
sometimes they'll just say because it is
okay that's a bad sign
but very often they'll be able to
introspect and so on so one of the
questions um i often ask is i'll point
to a sentence with a pronoun in it and
i'll say
you know the referent of that pronoun is
obviously this noun over here
you know how would you or i or an a.i or
a five-year-old ten-year-old child
know that that pronoun refers to that
noun over here
and
often
the people who are going to be good at
ontological engineering will give me
some causal explanation or will refer to
some things that are true in the world
so if you imagine a sentence like the
horse was led into the barn while its
head was still wet
and so its head refers to the horse's
head but how do you know that and so
some people will say i just know it some
people will say well the horse was the
subject of the sentence
and i'll say okay well what about the
horse was led into the barn while its
roof was still wet now its roof
obviously refers to the barn
and so then they'll say oh well that's
because it's the closest noun and so on
so basically if they try to give me
answers which are based on syntax and
grammar and so on that's a really bad
sign but if they're able to say things
like well horses have heads and barns
don't and barns have roofs and horses
don't
then that's a positive sign that they're
going to be good at this because they
can introspect on what's true in the
world
that leads you to know certain things
how fascinating is it that getting a phd
makes you less capable to introspect
deeply about this kind of oh i wouldn't
i wouldn't know that far i'm not saying
that it makes you less capable let's
just say it's independent
of oh i don't know how of how good
people are you're not saying that i'm
saying that there's a certain cut it's
it's interesting
that for a lot of people uh phds uh
sorry philosophy aside that sometimes
education narrows your thinking versus
expands it yes it's kind of fascinating
and for certain when you're trying to do
ontological engineering which is
essentially teach our future ai
overlords how to
reason deeply about this world and how
to understand it
that that requires that you think deeply
about the world so i'll tell you a sad
story about math craft which is why is
that not widely used in schools today
we're not really trying to make
big profit on it or anything like that
when we we've gone to schools their
attitude has been well
if a student spends 20 hours going
through this math craft program from
start to end and so on
will it improve their score on this
standardized test more than if they
spent 20 hours just doing mindless
drills
of problem after problem after problem
and the answer is well no but it'll
increase their understanding more and
their attitude is well if it doesn't
increase their score
on this test
um then that's not you know we're not
going to adopt it
that's sad i mean that's that's a whole
that's a whole nother three four hour
conversation about the education system
but let me ask you let me go super
philosophical as if we weren't already
so in 1950 alan turing wrote the paper
that formulated the touring test yes and
he opened the paper with the question
can machines think
so what do you think can machines think
let me ask you this question absolutely
machines can think um certainly as well
as humans can think
um right we're meat machines
um just because they're not currently
made out of meat is just you know an
engineering solution decision
and so on so
of course of course machines can think i
think that there was a lot of
damage done
by people
misunderstanding touring's imitation
game
and
focus on
trying to
trying to get a chat bot to
fool other people into thinking it was
human
and so on that that's that's not a
terrible test in and of itself but it
shouldn't be your one and only test for
intelligence
so you uh in terms of tests of
intelligence uh you know
with the lobner prize which is a very
kind of
you want to say a more strict
formulation of the touring test as
originally formulated and then there's
something like alexa prize which is more
i would say a more interesting
formulation of the test which is like
uh
ultimately the metric is how long does a
human want to talk to the hai system so
it's like the goal is you want it to be
20 minutes
it's basically
not just have a
convincing
conversation but more like a compelling
one or a fun one or an interesting one
and that that seems like more to the
spirit
maybe of um
of what uh touring was imagining but
what for you do you think in the space
of tests is a is a good test like when
you see a system based on psych that
passes that test
you'd be like damn
we've created something special here
the the test has to be something
involving
depth of reasoning and recursiveness of
reasoning the ability to answer
repeated why questions about the answer
you just gave
it's how many wide questions in a row
can you keep answering something
something like that and
um
have like a young curious child and an
ai system and how long will any ad
system last before it wants to quit yes
and again that's not the only test
another one has to do with argumentation
in other words here's a proposition um
come up with pro and con
arguments
for it and try and
give me convincing arguments on both
sides
and
so that's that's another important kind
of ability that
the system needs to be able to exhibit
in order to really be
intelligent i think so there's certain i
mean if you look at ibm watson and like
certain impressive accomplishments for
very specific
tests almost like a demo right um there
is some
uh like i talked to the guy who led
the
the jeopardy effort
and there's some kind of hard-coding
heuristics uh tricks that you try to
pull it all together to make the thing
work in the end for this thing right
that seems to be one of the lessons with
ai is like
that's the fastest way to get a solution
that's pretty damn impressive so so here
here's what i would say is that
as impressive as that was
it made some mistakes but more
importantly
many of the mistakes it made were
mistakes which no human would have made
yeah
and
so part of the
the the
new
or augmented touring tests would have to
be
and the mistakes you make are ones which
humans don't basically look at and say
what
yeah
so for example
there was a
um a question about which 16th century
italian politician blah blah blah and
watson said ronald reagan
so most americans would have gotten that
question wrong but they would never have
said ronald reagan as an answer
because
you know
among the things they know is that he
lived relatively recently and people
don't really live 400 years and you know
things like that so that that's i think
a very important thing which is um if
it's making mistakes which
no normal sane human would have made
then that's a really bad sign and if
it's not making those kinds of mistakes
then that's a good sign and i don't
think it's any one very very simple test
i think it's all of the things you
mentioned all the things i mentioned
there's really a battery of tests which
together if it passes almost all of
these tests it'd be hard to argue that
it's not intelligent and if it fails
some several of these tests it's really
hard to argue that it really understands
what it's doing that it really is
generally intelligent so to pass all of
those tests
you know we've talked a lot about psych
and knowledge and reasoning
do you think this ai system would need
to have some other human-like elements
for example a body
or a physical manifestation in this
world
and another one which seems to be
fundamental to
the human experience is consciousness
the subjective experience of what it's
like to actually be you
do you think he needs those to be able
to pass all those tests and to achieve
general intelligence it's a good
question i think in the case of a body
uh no i know there are a lot of people
like penrose who would have uh disagreed
with me and so on
and
and others but
no i don't think it needs to have a body
in order to be
intelligent i think that it needs to be
able to talk about
uh having a body and having sensations
and having emotions and so on it doesn't
actually have to
have
all of that but it has to understand it
in the same way that helen keller was
perfectly intelligent and able to talk
about
colors and sounds and
shapes and
and so on even though
she didn't directly experience all the
same things that the rest of us do so
knowledge of it and being able to
correctly
make use of that
is certainly an important facility but
actually having a body
if you believe that that's just a kind
of religious or mystical belief you
can't really argue for or against it i
suppose um it's it's just something that
some people
that some people believe what about the
like an extension of the body which is
consciousness i mean like it feels like
something to be here
sure but you know what what does that
really mean it's like well if i talk to
you you say things which make me believe
that you're conscious
i know that i'm conscious but that's you
know you're just taking my word for it
now
but
in the same sense psych is conscious in
that same sense already where of course
it understands it's a computer program
it understands where and when it's
running it understands who's talking to
it it understands what its task is what
its goals are what its current problem
is that it's working on it understands
how long it's spent on things what it's
tried it understands what it's done in
the past
and so on um and
uh you know if if we want to call that
consciousness then yes psych is already
conscious but i don't think that i would
ascribe anything
mystical to that again some people would
but i would i would say that you know
other than other than our own personal
experience of consciousness um we're
just treating everyone else in the world
um so to speak um at their word about
being conscious and so if
if a computer program if an ai is able
to
exhibit
all the same kinds of
response as you would expect of a
conscious entity
then you know it doesn't doesn't it
deserve the label of consciousness just
as much so there's another burden that
comes with this whole intelligence thing
that humans got is uh
the extinguishing
of the light of consciousness which is
uh kind of realizing they were going to
be dead someday
and there's a bunch of philosophers like
ernest becker
who kind of think that this
realization of mortality and then
fear sometimes they call it terror of
of of mortality is one of the creative
forces
behind
human condition like it's the thing that
drives us do you think it's important
for an ai system you know
when psych
proposed that it's one it's not human
and it's one of the moderators of his
contents
um
you know there's another question you
could ask which is like it kind of knows
that humans are mortal
am immortal
and i think one really important
uh thing that's possible when you're
conscious
is to fear the extinguishing of that
consciousness the fear of mortality
do you think that's useful for
intelligence
thinking like i might die and i really
don't want to die i i don't think so i
think it may help
some humans to be
um better people it may help some humans
to be more creative
and so on i don't think it's necessary
for ais to
believe that they have limited lifespans
and therefore they should make the most
of their behavior maybe eventually
the answer to that and my answer to that
will change but as of now i would say
that that's almost like a frill or a
side effect that
is not in fact if you look at most
humans
most humans
um ignore the fact that they're going to
die most of the time
uh so
well but that's like
this goes to the white space between the
words
so what ernest becker argues is that
that ignoring is we're living an
illusion that we're constructed on the
foundation of this terror so we're
escape life as we know it
pursuing things creating things love
everything we can think of that's
beautiful about humanity is is just
trying to escape this realization that
we're going to die one day that's his
that's his idea and i think i don't know
if i i 100
believe in this but there's it certainly
rhymes it seems like to me like it
rhymes with the truth
yeah i i think that for some people
um
that's going to be a more powerful
factor than others clearly doug is
talking about russians
and
i think that uh
some russians so clearly it infiltrates
all of russian literature
and ai doesn't have to have
uh
fear of death as a motivating force in
that we can build in
motivation so we can build in the
motivation of
obeying users and making users happy and
making others happy and
and so on and
that can substitute for this sort of
personal fear of death that sometimes
leads to
bursts of creativity in in humans i
don't know i think like i think ai
really needs to understand death deeply
in order to be able to drive a car for
example
i i think there's just some
like there no i really disagree i think
it needs to understand the value of
human life especially the value of human
life to other humans
the um and understand that certain
things are more important than other
things it has to have a lot of knowledge
about ethics and
morality and so on but some of it is so
messy that it's impossible to encode for
example this is disagree so if there's a
person dying right in front of us
most human beings would help that person
but they would not apply that same
ethics to everybody else in the world
this is the tragedy of how difficult it
is to be a doctor
because they know when they help a dying
child
they know that the money they're
spending on this child
cannot possibly be spent on every other
child that's dying and that's
that's a very difficult to encode
decision
now
perhaps perhaps it is perhaps it could
be formalized oh but i mean you're
talking about
autonomous vehicles right so
autonomous vehicles are going to have to
make those decisions
um all the time of um what is the chance
of this bad event happening um how bad
is that compared to this chance of that
bad event happening and so on and you
know when a potential accident is about
to happen is it worth taking this risk
if i have to make a choice which of
these two cars am i going to hit and why
and see i was thinking about a very
different choice when i'm talking about
your mortality which is just observing
uh manhattan style driving
i think that humans as an effective
driver needs to threaten
pedestrians lives
a lot
there's a dance i've watched pedestrians
a lot of i worked on this problem and it
seems like
the the if i could summarize the problem
of a pedestrian crossing
is
the car with this movement is saying i'm
going to kill you and the pedestrian is
saying
maybe and then they decide and say no i
don't think you you have the guts to
kill me and you walk and they walk in
front and they look away
and there's that dance the the the
pedestrian as this is a social contract
that the pedestrian trusts that once
they're in front of the car and the car
is sufficiently from a physics
perspective able to stop they're going
to stop but the car also has to threaten
that pedestrians like i'm late for work
so you're being kind of an [ __ ] by
crossing in front of me but life and
death is in like is part of the
calculation here and it's that that
equation is being solved millions of
times a day
yes very effectively that game theory
whatever yeah whatever that formulation
absolutely i just i don't know if it's
as simple as some
formalizable game theory problem it it
could very well be in a case of driving
and in the case of most of uh
human society i i don't know but
it uh yeah you might be right that sort
of uh the fear of death is just one of
the quirks
of uh like the way our brains have
evolved but it's not it's not a
necessary feature of intelligence
drivers certainly are always doing this
kind of estimate even if it's
unconscious subconscious
of
what are the chances of various bad
outcomes happening like for instance
if i don't wait for this pedestrian or
something like that
and
what is the downside to me going to be
in terms of um you know time wasted
talking to the police or
um you know getting sent to jail or you
know things like that and so
um and there's also emotion like people
in their cars tend to get
uh irrationally angry that's that's
that's dangerous but you know think
think about this is all part of why i
think that autonomous vehicles um truly
autonomous vehicles are farther out
than than most people do because
there is this enormous level of
complexity which goes beyond
mechanically controlling the car
and
i i can see the autonomous vehicles as a
kind of metaphorical and literal
accident waiting to happen
um and not just because of
their um overall
um
incurring versus preventing accidents
and so on but just because of the
almost
voracious appetite people have
for
bad
bad stories about powerful companies and
powerful entities when when i was um
at a coincidentally japanese fifth
generation computing system conference
in 1987
while i happened to be there
there was a worker at an auto plant who
was despondent and committed suicide by
climbing under the safety chains and so
on getting stamped to death
by a machine and instead of being a
small story that said despondent worker
commits suicide it was front page news
that effectively said
robot kills worker
because the public is just waiting
for stories about like
a.i kills phonogenic family of five type
stories and even if you could show that
nationwide uh this system saved more
lives than it cost and saved more
injuries
prevented more injuries than it caused
and so on
the media the public the government is
just
coiled and ready to pounce
on stories where in fact it failed even
if there are relatively few
yeah it's so fascinating to watch us
humans resisting
the cutting edge of science and
technology and almost like hoping for it
to fail and constantly and you know
this just happens over and over and over
throughout history or even if we're not
hoping for it to fail we're we're
fascinated by it and in terms of what we
find interesting
um the one in a thousand failures much
more interesting than the 999
boring
successes so once we build an agi system
say psych is some part of some part of
it
and
say it's very possible that you would be
one of the first people
that can sit down in the room
let's say with her and have a
conversation
what would you ask her what would you
talk about
looking at all of the
content out there
on the web and so on
what are the
what are the some possible solutions to
big problems that the world has that
people haven't really thought of before
that are not being
properly or at least adequately
pursued
what are some novel solutions that you
can think of that we haven't
that might work and that might be worth
considering
so that is a damn good question given
that the agi is going to be somewhat
different from human intelligence
it's still going to make some mistakes
that we wouldn't make but it's also
possibly going to notice
some blind spots we have
and um i would i would love it
as a test of is it really
on a par with our intelligences
can it help spot some of the blind spots
that we have
so the two-part question of can you help
identify what are the big problems in
the world and two
what are some novel solutions to those
problems that are not being
talked about by anyone
yeah and some of those may become
um you know infeasible or reprehensible
or something but some of them might be
actually great things to look at you
know if you if you go back and look at
some of the most
powerful discoveries that have been made
uh like relativity and um
superconductivity and so on a lot of
them
were
cases where
someone took seriously the idea that
there might actually be
a non-obvious answer
to it to a question so in einstein's
case it was
yeah the lorenz transformation is known
um nobody believes that it's actually
the way reality works what if it were
the real way that reality actually
worked
so you know a lot of people don't
realize he didn't actually work out that
equation he just sort of took it
seriously um or in the case of
superconductivity you have this v equals
ir equation where r is resistance and so
on and um
it was being mapped at lower and lower
temperatures but everyone thought that
was just bump on a log research
to show that v equals ir always held
and then when some
graduate student
got to a slightly lower temperature and
showed that resistance suddenly dropped
off everyone just assumed that they did
it wrong and they and it was only a
little while later that they realized it
was um it was actually a new phenomenon
or in the case of um
the
h pylori bacteria causing stomach ulcers
where everyone thought that stress and
stomach acid caused ulcers
and when a doctor
in
australia
claimed it was actually a bacterial
infection
he couldn't get anyone seriously to
listen to him and he had to
ultimately inject himself
with the bacteria to show that he
suddenly developed a life-threatening
ulcer
in order to get other doctors to
seriously consider that so there are all
sorts of things where
humans are locked into paradigms what
thomas kuhn called paradigms and we
can't get out of them very easily so a
lot of ai is locked into the
deep learning machine learning paradigm
right now
and um almost all of us and almost all
sciences are locked into current
paradigms and you know kun's point was
pretty much you have to wait for people
to die
um in order for the new generation to
escape those paradigms and i think that
one of the things that would change that
sad reality is if we had
trusted agis that could help take a step
back
and question some of the paradigms that
we're currently locked into
yeah it would accelerate the paradigm
shifts and yes in human science and
progress
you've
lived a very interesting life where you
thought about big ideas and you stuck
with them
can you give advice to young people
today somebody in high school somebody
undergrad
about um
career about life
i'd say you can make a difference
but in order to make a difference you're
going to have to have the courage
to
follow through with ideas which
other people might not
immediately understand or
support you have to
realize that if you make
some
some plan that's going to take an
extended period of time to carry out
don't be afraid of that that's true of
um
physical training of your body that's
true of
um
learning
some profession that's also true of
innovation that some innovations are not
great ideas you can write down on a
napkin
and become an instant success if you
turn out to be right some of them are
paths you have to follow but
remember that you're mortal remember
that you have a limited number of
decade sized debts to make with your
life
and you should make each one of them
count and that's true in personal
relationships that's true in career
choice that's true in
making discoveries and so on and if you
follow the path of least resistance
you'll find that
you're optimizing for
short periods of time
and before you know it you turn around
and long periods of time have gone by
without you ever really making a
difference in the world you know there's
when you look i mean the field that i
really love is artificial intelligence
and there's not many projects there's
not many
little flames of hope that have been
carried out for many years for decades
and psych represents one of them
and uh
i mean that in itself is just a really
inspiring thing
so i'm i'm deeply grateful that you
would be carrying that flame for so many
years and i think that's an inspiration
to young people that said you said life
is finite and we talked about mortality
is a feature of agi
do you think about your own mortality
are you afraid of death
um
sure i'd be crazy if i weren't and um as
i get older i'm now um over 70. so as i
get older
it's more on my mind especially as
acquaintances and friends and especially
mentors
one by one are dying so i can't
avoid
thinking about mortality and i think
that
the good news from the point of you and
the rest of the world is that that adds
impetus
to
my need to succeed in a small number of
years in the future
because i have a deadline
exactly i'm not going to have another 37
years to continue working on this so we
really do want psych to
make an impact in the world
commercially
physically metaphysically
in the next small number of years two
three five years not two three five
decades anymore and so this is really
driving me toward
uh this this sort of commercialization
and increasing increasingly widespread
application
of psych whereas before
i felt that i could just sort of sit
back roll my eyes wait till the world
caught up and now i don't feel that way
anyway anymore i feel like i need to put
in some effort to
make the world aware of what we have and
what it can do
and the good news from your point of
view is that that's that's why i'm
sitting here and you're gonna be more
productive
[Laughter]
uh
i love it and if i can help in any way i
would love to from uh from you know from
a programmer perspective
i love
especially these days just contributing
in small and big ways so if there's any
open sourcing from the mit side and the
research i would love to help
but
you know bigger than psych like i said
it's that little flame that you're
carrying of artificial intelligence the
big dream
is there
what do you hope your legacy is
hmm
that's a good question
that people think of me as
one of the pioneers or inventors
of
the ai that is ubiquitous and that they
take for granted
and so on much much the way that
today we look back on the the pioneers
of electricity or the pioneers of
similar types of technologies and so on
as
you know it's hard to imagine what life
would be like if these people hadn't
done what they
um what they did so that that's one
thing
that i'd like to be remembered as
another is that so the creator one of
the origin originators of this
gigantic
knowledge
store and acquisition system that is
likely to be at the center
of whatever this future ai thing will
look like exactly and i'd also like to
be remembered as someone who
wasn't afraid to
spend
several decades
on a project in a time when
all when almost all of the
other forces
institutional forces and commercial
forces
are incenting people to go for
short-term rewards and a lot of people
gave up a lot of people that
dreamt the same dream as you
gave up yes and you didn't yes
i mean uh doug it's truly an honor this
was a long time coming i i
a lot of people bring up your work
uh specifically and more broadly
philosophically of this is the dream of
artificial intelligence this is likely a
part of the future we're so sort of
focused on machine learning applications
all that kind of stuff today but it
seems like the ideas that psych carries
forward
uh is something that would be at the
center
of this problem they're all trying to
solve which is the the problem of
intelligence
emotional and
and uh otherwise so thank you so much
it's such a huge honor that you would
talk to me and spend your valuable time
with me today thanks for talking thanks
alex it's been great
thanks for listening to this
conversation with doug lennon to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you some words from
mark twain about the nature of truth
if you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
thank you for listening i hope to see
you next time